um
okay
uh
this is not too bad
so
good morning everyone i'm going to go
ahead and open the public hearing on hb
1278 and i will call representative
terry roy to speak to his bill
thank you good morning honorable members
of the committee i'm here today to
introduce hb 1278
whenever i introduce one of my bills i
never asked the committee to pass it i
never say please
get this otp i ask you only to consider
it
you decide whether it's otp
this bill was brought to me the idea for
by a constituent it's going to tell you
a short story and this happened most
recently and i'd like to start by
acknowledging the committee's hard work
they did in recent years
working on the alimony laws of this
state and making them much more
predictable
i hope that this proposed bill would
have no effect on that predictability or
the hard work you've already done back
to my story
so a constituent this is a woman she was
about 54 years old
she had been married for over 20 years
she was a stay-at-home mom
during the birth of her second child
she
cut an injury that turned into
fibromyalgia
and she had a lot of health issues
so she
continued being a stay-at-home mom
until they get into their 50s and and
then been married several decades
well her husband at that time had been
become very successful
and he
was making somewhere in the mid six
figures
and everything was great
until such time as he decided that he'd
had enough
and he actually uh ended up marrying his
26 year old secretary
well this was devastating for the woman
but thanks to the predictability of our
laws
she knew that she will get some alimony
and she'd have a way to live
as a stay-at-home mom she had never
contributed to social security so she
did not qualify for social security
disability because she had no quarters
that she had put in
so her sole means of support
was that alimony
now
several months after the divorce was
final the husband threw a big wedding
for his new bride
they traveled had a huge honeymoon it
was all over facebook
difficult but such is life
and the problem now for her is
she's frozen in time
she's 50 something years old doesn't
have much time left to build a
relationship
if she
starts a dating relationship
or she decides to cohabitate with
someone she can fall in love with and
continue her life with she loses her
alimony
as the law is written it says a
substantial relationship or if they
cohabitate
now
this law proposes to fix that in that
it's still cohabitation and a
relationship
can lead to the withdrawal of alimony
but first the judge has to make findings
it's not just the fact that she's fallen
in love and moved in with someone or
that they're in a substantial delayed
dating relationship
it has to be proven that that
relationship
is providing substantial financial
benefit to her
such as was already contemplated excuse
me by the judge
excuse me i got a frog
by the judge in his findings for the
alimony in the first place alimony is
designed to help both parties maintain
their standard of living as close as
possible
so should the new relationship
impact that that would be grounds to
withdraw the alimony
however
if the woman 54 years old 55 disabled
meets another man
and he also is disabled and they both
just get a check
and they decide you know what let's live
together she loses her alimony she loses
her support based on the fact that she's
living with someone he doesn't have the
means to help her or to increase her
standard of living it's just two people
who want to live together and not be
alone
the way we have the law you know we hear
words like
like um
misogyny and patriarchy we hear them so
much that they become to mean nothing
and that's sad because it still does
exist
these laws were written a long time ago
and they were designed for men
if a woman
at 55 years old
can't date but her husband her
ex-husband
can marry his 25-year-old secretary and
have children start a whole new life but
god forbid she wants to do the same she
loses her only means of support
so all this law does is say look
those are definitely grounds to do your
alimony
but at least there has to be a finding
made that there's been a contribution
that would offset
the need for alimony
so as i said in the beginning i would
ask you to consider this law
and give it its due thought and
whatever you decide i respect thank you
very much
are there any questions for the
representative
representative yokela
thank you and thank you for
for taking my question
if the person
is part of a new relationship
the
the alimony is based off of the standard
of living of the old relationship but if
they accepted this person that
has less money aren't they also
accepting that the new financial status
of the relationship thank you
indeed which is why you're absolutely
correct which is why the judge would
have to make a finding that the new
relationship brought financial benefit
and if it did
that would offset the alimony that's
correct
so
you're saying that
the
only way that it should be uh
considered that she's accepting the new
relationship and the financial impact
and all of that is if it it
increases her current standard of living
but not if she's not able to accept a
new relationship with a lower standard
of living
and
and the other relationship be completely
separated at that point
is that what your position is
let me see if i can
answer that
in an example so that we understand what
we're both asking
the the man
remarries he's off on his own he's got
his new wife the woman
gets alimony that's her sole means of
support
if
if she begins dating or moves in with
someone
who has no money but perhaps their own
social security check
because now we're talking about people
in their 50s and 60s
that alone should not be grounds to
terminate her alimony
unless the standard of living that was
contemplated by the judge in the divorce
is met
through the contributions of the new
relationship
if the new relationship does not provide
a
financial benefit
so that without the alimony
she'd be still living at the standard of
living contemplated by the judge
originally then it should not have an
effect on her ability to keep getting
her alimony
i hope that answers
representative de simone
i'm sorry
oh
oh never mind
are there any further questions
representative yokela
yes thank you and thank you for taking
this question
is it possible
in your example that the person could
end up with two alimonies because the
first one
the the second marriage
the person made less than the first
marriage
no
i don't
maybe you should rephrase the question i
i don't understand it
so
under the first alimony the only way for
it to be removed is if they get
remarried
and have a financial benefit
but you're saying if the person that
they remarried doesn't give them that
much of a financial benefit as the first
husband then the first alimony should
count
like still stay and then the person
could get divorced again
and uh from the second husband and then
get a second alimony because the first
alimony is still there and the second
alimony is there
um
i would say no because if they got a
second alimony that would offset the
first alimony and furthermore we already
agreed that the second husband
doesn't have any money to provide
alimony
so
possibly strangely it could potentially
happen that but i believe that the first
alimony would be offset by the second
alimony
so if she got divorced a second time
and that person
although we agreed doesn't have any more
money than she does
is tasked with paying her alimony first
of all they'd have to meet the length of
the marriage
now we're talking about people in their
50s but assuming all that arguemendo
happens
the judge from the first alimony case
would reduce the alimony from the first
husband based on the fact that she now
has more income
so i think it would offset
are you good representative yokela
i'd be happy if you just email me i'd be
happy to
anyone on the committee
okay representative de simone
thank you madam chair and thank you
representative for taking my question
i'm confused now
i thought i understood this
can you clarify for me if
the female
who is receiving
alimony
moves in and lives with another person
the alimony continues
are you saying that if she marries this
other person you want the alimony to
continue
i am minus a finding from the judge
that the new marriage
would
raise the standard of living beyond the
alimony so if two poor people get
married that doesn't necessarily mean
that the first person is living better
if two people living on social security
get remarried or get married that
doesn't mean that the other person
should lose their alimony from the first
marriage that they spent 20 or 30 years
involved in
simply because they moved in with
someone or married someone
only upon the finding that they married
a person who has money and is paying
further and if you look at the bill it
specifically says pays for their
cohabitation provides a means of
transportation those are indicators that
okay this person is benefiting
financially
from this new marriage it seems to me um
just on its face so unfair that one
party can remarry have kids a whole new
family and the other person cannot
remarry without losing their means of
support even if the person they fall in
love with is poor it just doesn't seem
fundamentally fair
thank you no further questions
are there any further questions for
representative roy
did i call you representative terry
earlier
you may have thought
that's why i got into the whole trouble
with rescheduling the wrong bill
all right thank you very much thank you
up next is
richard head to provide information
magic terror members of the committee my
name is richard head i'm the government
affairs coordinator for the judicial
branch following representative roy is
hard he's much taller than i am
uh okay there we go um so
as as was in my card i'm here to provide
information we do not have a position on
this bill um
but
the bill as written will have an impact
on the judicial branch and i just wanted
to talk through sort of how this
involves the judicial branch and how
it may
have an impact in terms of how we would
interpret this bill or have to manage
this bill
and i'd point to lines five and six on
the bill
which strikes the cohabitation
requirement
and inserts that the payee has remarried
or is involved in a new romantic
relationship so there's two parts to it
either either
remarried or involved in a new romantic
relationship the new romantic
relationship is the part that at least
creates some some issues as to how
that's going to be interpreted it's not
otherwise used in statutes it's not
otherwise used in this
particular law
so there's going to have to be some
interpretation as to what that means and
how
firm does that new remo
the romantic relationship have to be can
it be a date can it be you know how
extensive is that relationship
is going to have to be interpreted
in lines 10 to 12
this is where sort of judicial resources
become involved
it talks about
some of the criteria of
when it is that the the
alimony could be amended
and it talks about assistance in paying
household utilities beyond the amount
necessary to cover the cost of
additional persons and again this could
be in the context of a
romantic relationship there's going to
be litigation over that there's going to
be discovery over who's paying what
bills
and
with regard to a person who is in a
relationship
with another
we anticipate that's going to create
litigation create additional workloads
on
staff and and judges
in just in terms of litigating that
language
line 23 makes a reference to
cohabitation and it becomes sort of
unclear as to
given the fact that cohabitation was
struck as the standard why would being
there my guess is that's just an error
in the drafting but we pointed out
because that just creates more confusion
in terms of how the courts would now
have to interpret this
i also just note and again i think this
is just an error line two which
references the section
458.99-a
think that should be 19-aaa not 99
so i think that's just a typo
and then with regard to line 18 which
repeals section 8 and some of this is is
sort of unclear again in terms of how
the courts would interpret this that
paragraph eight is the current law
that one if the bright line test of
cohabitation is met
section eight outlines the criteria by
which the court would then evaluate
whether or not alimony is no longer fair
or just and it includes sort of the
financial sharing that occurs in that
cohabitation relationship
and
economic independence and has other
considerations in that paragraph so that
would be struck for this new section
which in which involves those who are in
a
romantic relationship
it has similar criteria as what's in
that section eight
but once you strike that and you add new
ones the court now has to come through a
new set of trying to interpret and
figure out what was intended by that
change um so
as written at least
the the law is going to create new
elements of interpretation for the court
likely to increase some litigation
over those who are simply involved in a
romantic relationship over the financial
status of those two parties um so we do
anticipate an additional workload on the
courts with that i'd be happy to answer
any questions
are there any questions for mr head
seeing none thank you very much thank
you
okay so that's the last of the pink
cards that i have for 12.70 oh no
1278 vivian gerard to speak in
opposition of the bill and she has um
written testimony so
if you're going to give us written
testimony please don't read your
testimony because we can read it just
give your testimony as you you know
there you would
use it as a guide how's that yeah that's
fine okay so um
thank you uh chair and members of the
house committee
uh my name is will you pull the mic down
a little
i i think it
representative roy is very tall
yes
yes thank you
hi my name is vivian gerard and i'm here
to
um
a little closer okay close to the bill
but
if it was modified slightly i would
probably be more in favor of the bill
so just to give you a quick little
background about me is
i'm actually the silva v silva case for
the child support calculator i know that
you probably are wondering why i'm here
but because what happened to me
back in
2014 when i separated
i was awarded alimony and during my
divorce
the judge had way too many discretions
when she was going ahead and
ruling on my case
and
with alimony at the time
she gave me six months to close my
business
and if not she was going to take away
child support and alimony and she did
just that so unfortunately
with me
the alimony was supposed to help offset
some of the bills from the family
and unfortunately the judge at the time
put on false
deviations on my case which eliminated
my child support and the alimony
and the way that
the next bill is going to be
for the um child support
if that bill passes people like me
will actually get hurt by it okay but
we're not talking about that bill okay
let's stay on this one and if you follow
where i'm going with this is
if you're going to go ahead and pass
this bill you should take into
consideration
previous
people that had alimony that was taken
away from them
because if if the child support and
alimony kind of go hand in hand if one
gets taken away the other one should be
compensated
for the downfall of the difference in
calculations
so in my
defense here
i would like to see an amendment to the
bill
saying that
if people have been
awarded alimony in the past
and if this
in this case if if the child support
actually goes through
then we should be able to have a
reevaluation
of our alimony in this case
so that's what i would like to be
considered as you guys go ahead and pass
this bill
okay thank you thank you um would you
believe that alimony and child support
are two totally separate issues they are
separate issues but when it's actually
supplying funding for a house especially
if the couple is married
married for 20 years
and
it was actually in my case i was asked
to stay home and take care of our
children one of my daughters has a
disability
and she's now 15. and during my my
divorce hearing
um they said that i was underemployed to
go out and get a job
unfortunately with my daughter's
disability that was not an option
so
in my case
i was awarded alimony and that should
have stayed
because i am the primary caregiver for
my children
so are you telling me that they took
away your alimony because you got child
support correct
okay they gave they did give me full
child support and the way that the judge
did it she said that
well
i didn't get full child support right
away i'm actually still fighting for it
um but recently i did get awarded full
child support but
in the in the very beginning she did
give me full child support so i could
eliminate alimony and then
then it this has been going on for seven
years so i apologize if it sounds
confusing so it was on it was off it was
on it was off so the whole time i should
have been getting alimony that could
have kept me and my children afloat but
it didn't because every time
the child support was up on appeal
i lost all child support and i didn't
have the alimony so i relied on
taxpayers funding to help keep me and my
family afloat and that is not the job of
a taxpayers to help people like me
that was at home because of my children
that was a family decision
that was me compromising my employment
for my family
and if he's making a hundred and fifty
thousand dollars a year
the tax payer should not be burdened in
order to keep my family
on food stamps
i mean that's
kind of part of the reason that you have
alimony and child support so that it
does not fall on the taxpayer as a
burden
and right now the way it is they should
reevaluate situations like mine not
everybody is a cookie cutter calculation
it should be more of like a flow chart
if you've been married for x amount of
years you should be doing this if you if
in my case
i i stayed in the family home i could
not afford to move out of the family
home so again another reason of the
alimony was also there to help
maintain
equal living for my children so they did
not have to leave the school system
he made so much money that he could go
out and get another apartment i didn't
have that
so i struggled for seven years it's been
a seven year sentence in my life
trying to stay afloat trying to keep
equal living from my children trying not
to disrupt them by taking them out of
the school system
so this all falls back on how it affects
the children how it affects the
household and if in my case i was
married for almost 20 years it was 19
years by the time we finally got our
official divorce
and
unfortunately in my case
it was very unique and i will say that
so i would like that to be considered
thank you are there any questions
seeing none thank you very much you want
me to hand you these testimonies you can
just
put them at the back at the end and they
can pass them around okay thank you
okay so pardon me one last thing is i
brought this i forgot to show you this
is what happens when you're trying to
fight for alimony and child support this
is one here i and and trust me i know
i've lived through it i get it i do
okay so that was the last pink card for
hb 1278 so i'll close the hearing on hb
1278 thank you very much i'll give the
clerk just a second to get his paperwork
organized and we'll open the next
hearing
representative boyd do you have a pink
card filled out
it has to come to us yeah
so
okay thank you everyone
i'm going to open the public hearing on
hb 1623
and i will call on representative boyd
it appears he just brought it to me
okay um
to speak in support of the bill and he
needed five minutes
thank you madam chair and through you to
my esteemed colleagues at the new
hampshire general court
my name is bill boyd i'm the
representative from hillsboro district
21 representing the town of merrimack
and i introduce to you and ask for your
support of house bill 1623 which
provides a one-time 1.3
cost of living adjustment for the daily
reimbursement rate for foster parents
i am a former foster parent and now
adoptive parent with my wife michelle to
our daughter jade
as many of you are well aware foster
kids bring a level of richness
to a foster family's life whether it's
being
a short-term integration or to a
permanent temporary long-term
integration
the 900-plus foster kids that
reside in the state of new hampshire
rely on foster families to provide them
with the
everyday quality of life that all
families give to
to all of their kids and grandkids you
know safety security food a roof over
their head clothes on their backs that
kind of thing
i ask that we increase
the cost of living adjustment by 1.3
percent on a couple of different things
number one social security
uh in the fall of last year raised their
benefit caller to 5.9 percent for all of
their benefits
number two is roughly this was last
updated
in july of 2018
so the
what i would consider a a nominal bump
in the caller
in light of
when it was last stop stay updated
versus what social security has done
versus the the cost of
being able to put food on the table for
for a family today i think is
worthy of this committee's consideration
to make sure
that
the kids that are entrusted in our care
and in the foster family's care through
dcyf through department of health and
service health and human services
that the everyday needs of these
children are being met
it's that simple i thank you very much
for your time and i'd be more than happy
to answer any of your questions
are there any questions for
representative boyd
representative ocala
thank you thank you for taking the
question how is the um
current uh
rate
set
define what you mean by current rate
well you're trying to increase the daily
rate so how is it currently set is it in
dhhs
rules or is it in statute
my understanding is it's in statute
that's my understanding based on the
current
rate sheet that i looked at that i have
a copy of here
this specific
categories you have generalized care
specialized care
emerging care crisis care
if when when my wife and i adopted our
daughter she was she was 12 or 13 at the
time if we were to doctor at this
particular time based on the current
rate
it's 27.86
daily so it would be 1.3 percent off of
that which would be an increase of
roughly
40 cents
quick arithmetic in my head
can i follow up
so i'm trying so i'm trying to
understand why you put in
that the amount of the adjustments shall
be one percent increase instead of just
if it's in statute just adjusting the
statute that lists all of the amounts
when i
went to work
being new to the legislature and when i
went to work with ols on this
my impetus was looking at the cost of
living adjustment based on specific
indices whether it be libor whether it
be
social security whether it be department
of labor i was looking at a percentage
increase i wasn't exactly
looking specifically
at a rate at a specific line item rate
increase that's delineated on the
website representative
so that's how i was thinking about it
should i have thought about it
differently
follow-up
um i'm i'm not familiar with where the
this
those amounts are put
who
who pays this amount is it the taxpayers
yes
thank you
are there any further questions
saying none
wait a minute representative litchfield
thank you for taking my question you're
welcome
so i'm just the same as representative
ocala i'm just trying to understand so i
understand why you went with percentage
versus dollar amount this is the advice
that you've been given
curious why the one percent and do you
feel that am i hearing you correctly 40
excuse me 40 cents above the daily rate
will this make a difference i'm just
trying to understand so i'm trying to be
prudential with the taxpayers money i
easily could have asked for the same
cost of living adjustment that social
security gave their retirees a 5.9
percent i felt that that might be overly
onerous
i thought based on
current projections and what the
legislative legislature did historically
back in 18 which was 1.3 percent i felt
that that would be
based on on what what we've done
historically would be an appropriate
increase for the for the committee and
for the house to consider as opposed to
5.9 which i
quite honestly based on
current numbers i felt would be a little
bit
a little bit more
less prudential than what i would
view how we would be spending the
taxpayer dollar
thank you you're welcome
are there any further questions
seeing none thank you very much madam
chair for you and my colleagues thank
you for hearing me out thank you
so that's the um
only pink card i had for hb 1623 so i
will close the hearing on hb 1623 and we
will be back at 10 am
here
uh
you
i'm running over
okay
well you know what it is
they always get a little aggressive with
the scissors
uh
yes
so i said
in my testimony
um
get your roller skates on yeah
okay good morning everyone
i'm going to open the
public hearing on
house bill 1647
and
representative abrami has asked for five
minutes
thank you madam chair
catching my breath i just ran over from
the other room what's that i didn't get
the memo that we moved the room
[Music]
so okay you're not alone
uh thank you madam chair um for the
record state rep patarami
strata rockingham 19 stratum
i agreed to
be the prime sponsor of this bill
because i instinctively know
joint custody of children of divorced
parents
is best for the children and society as
a whole
i am not an expert in these matters at
all
however this bill has been created by
those who are very knowledgeable in this
topic
it is
it is well understood in research that
children do their best with parents who
share equal and nearly equal parenting
time
many parents who seek
to take part in raising their children
their child in a meaningful and
significant way in new hampshire
find themselves challenged
with the new hampshire laws on child
support
in 2018 in the new hampshire supreme
court
made a judgment
in its interpretation of the existing
rsas
on the modification of child support for
parenting time
in silva v silva
with their strict interpretation of the
term fixed
modification of a full child support
order cannot be made without a reduction
in fixed costs of the parent who earns
less income resulting in a full child
support being awarded to the other part
parent
this this was never the intention of
our rsas
before silva v silver
there was a genuine recognition
that while children are
in a parent's care
there are costs to to uh to care for
for them
prior to this judgment seventy percent
of all orders were modified and
parenting time was
the primary reason
also in in 2018
a 500
000 dollar research report funded by new
hampshire and conducted by the casey
carsey institute of unh
was completed and presented to this
committee and to the department of
health and human services
this bill is a reflection of the
recommendations in this report requests
and requests of our family courts
then in
the case of anderson v anderson was
brought to the new hampshire supreme
court
this case had to do with shared
parenting and fixed costs
upon one of the anderson's
seeking relief that relief
was denied
but the reason was
the supreme court pointed back to the
legislature
to the legislature
to address the law
as there was no such guideline for child
support for which the courts could
follow
this this bill provides that guideline
in 2001
just last year
a similar bill to this is passed in the
committee and on the house floor
that bill language was not accepted by
the senate judiciary committee
in this bill house bill 1647
we have made some simplifying language
changes and addressed the percentage of
child support allocated
for higher wage earners
we will
be working with the appropriate senators
to garner support for these much-needed
changes
in our statutes if this bill does indeed
pass through the house
madam chair i will take questions
but for specifics of the bill
your questions are better answered by
brenda towne right behind me here
who has worked tirelessly over the years
to solve this problem
thank you madam chair
thank you are there any questions for
representative abrami okay i'm gonna
look that way no that's what i was
helping you go like this
representative outshiller
thank you madam chair good eyes
so
thank you representative abrami for
taking my question
on page
two
lines 18 and 19 relative to adjustments
to the child support guidelines due to
lower fixed costs resulting from equal
or approximately equal residential
responsibility is that referring to
page one line eight representative
rochelle
as i said
uh for specifics i refer you to
brenda town
okay she helped she helped craft the
language
and she would know better than me
okay all right okay your bill thank you
are there any further questions
seeing none thank you very much thank
you
up next we might as well call on brenda
town
who's asked for three minutes
and i am gonna say before we go any
further if you have written testimony
that's wonderful but i ask that you not
read it to us we can read the testimony
just kind of highlight some of the spots
throughout it please
definitely thank you for that coaching
and i just want to thank you and thank
this committee for hearing me today i've
spoken before the committee before and i
know many of you have been here working
a while on this committee and
i know you aren't highly paid so
i appreciate that you're putting your
time and effort into this
my name is brenda towne and i'm a mother
of four kids a grandmother of 8.25
grandchildren
and i became the unwitting
advocate for parents in new hampshire
because of a family situation
so
i ended up in the throes of this with a
custody battle
that involved my four young
grandchildren and as i waded deeper and
deeper into the
bowels of our laws
i recognized that there were things that
just weren't working well and it
catapulted me to become a parental
advocate
i led a group of 5 000 parents on
facebook on a daily basis i triaged
inbound calls from parents who were just
struggling and in bad shape
and um
i just need you to talk about the bill
yeah okay so i just wanted to give that
as a background because it led me to in
into this space for child support
because this was one critical area that
was affecting those parents so i so i've
included in my testimony a little
history because i went through it and
about a decade ago we had a bill hb
which transitioned into hb 378
and that was a shared parenting bill
that became a child support bill
and um from there it rolled into a study
and in 2016 we agreed to do this study
on child support statewide and you heard
representative romney talk about the
fact that we paid five hundred thousand
dollars to have the car seat school to
do that research study it involved
interviewing lawyers judges gals
social workers and also research into
our own new hampshire practices
and with that work they brought forward
three recommendations
and the three recommendations they
brought forward are represented in this
bill now we had the
wonderful opportunity of two worlds
colliding at once as this research paper
was coming forward silva v silva was
judged in our supreme courts so the
report came out and it didn't consider
the impact of our legend of our judges
not being able to now modify child
support based on parenting time that was
the bottom line of silva v silva unless
a parent could prove that fixed costs of
the other parent were reduced and they'd
used a very uh webster definition on
fixed cost which was
household
mortgage rent car there was no
modification
so since that time period parents who
have entered our family courts have
faced down fighting for the custody of
their kids because we all know that's
the right thing for their kids but at
the same time our child support orders
were not contemporary and they didn't
keep up with the trend
so we end up today with um households
sharing 50 50 responsibility of raising
the kids but our child support orders
are issued from the higher earner and
100 of that is given to the other
household
now what that has done is it has
hamstrung
that second household that's handing out
this child support order and again it's
based um you know it goes through our
standard worksheet i provided my
testimony and in the back i provided my
son's actual worksheet
and you can see that he made roughly a
thousand dollars more
than his the other parent
but the the court ordered a child
support order of
and they awarded the entire order
from him to his ex
and when you put the finances together
in their houses it ended up that
his household
was about
around 1100 a month less than hers and i
have the numbers in here and i promised
i wouldn't read it
so we know that this is a problem and
this is happening every day
so what this bill and what the
recommendations from car seat did is it
said you know what today
we have more and more shared parenting
households
and so what we're going to do is
recognize that there's a cost associated
with having two households so they
raised the overall order by 150 percent
so there's a 50 percent more allocation
of funds put in the pool for the parents
to manage the kids knowing full well
that there's two households
it is then allocated based on income to
the respective households but there is a
credit
for
the parenting time that is given based
on the full order so if the full order
let's say was three thousand dollars and
there was a 60 40 split of how that
order would be
generated
that order would be raised by a hundred
and fifty percent
but yet
sixty forty percent of the parenting
time credit against that original order
would be applied to the parent who paid
the child support
thereby reducing the cost so in my son's
case the example i included his child
support with four children which
garners about a forty percent gross
income child support order which is huge
went from a thousand one hundred dollars
down to about 250.
there and leveled the houses and again
the numbers are in this
paperwork for you
so
last year we worked really hard to get
this bill
and this committee supported us and we
thank you for that
we're stuck because we have nowhere to
go we've been told by our own supreme
court you need to come back and figure
this out with the legislators
so we need your help all right
right now and i've included again in
this document a layout of the child
support orders for identical family
compositions around our country
you'll see that new hampshire is number
three in the highest child support
orders in the country
we are 40 percent higher than the mean
of our entire country
there's a problem and we need to fix it
we were given feedback last year that
the reason why this didn't pass was
under the covers two things
one item was there was a real concern
that there would be an influx of parents
who came in and said please update my
order now that you've fixed this problem
that's been going on all right
so that i don't think that should scare
us i think we should figure out how to
manage that
the second thing which is most learning
is that we
as a state get eight million dollars a
year in matches for our child support
court orders due to title four d
if we modify these orders to bring them
down to respect shared parenting the
match will go down
and i would hope and pray that the state
of new hampshire would not use that as a
justification to not make these
well-overdue
changes that need to happen for our
families so i leave you with one of my
favorite verses
it's micah 6 4 and it says seek justice
love mercy and walk humbly before our
god
and i ask you today
to give us justice
thank you
okay are there any questions from this
town
representative altschiller
thank you madam chair and thank you miss
town for traveling from stratham to come
bring this bill i appreciate it um so
i'm going to ask you the question that i
had asked representative abrami
um for
[Music]
um
in the very on the second page of the
bill
lines 18 and 19
relative to adjustments to the child
support guidelines due to lower fixed
costs
resulting from equal or approximately
equal residential responsibility
um
i'm
i have two questions one is what are
those fixed costs and where are they
where are they annotated
so i can refer back to that and also
in on line eight does it refer do those
two lines refer back to page one line
eight
referencing child overnights
so the fixed cost was not intended to to
be an exact
um prescription
the problem that we ran into was with
silva v silva there was a webster
definition used and so the reduction of
fixed costs from a broader context is
opposed to just simply using a car
payment and rent
we look at the fixed costs of raising a
children the food the clothing all of
the things associated with raising a kid
and having them in your household so
that would be my interpretation of the
fixed costs we're referring to
where we got feedback in prior years is
that there had been no definition of
what shared parenting was and that was a
stumbling block
so the most likely and most commonly
used definition of shared parenting is
overnight time
because that normally drives the number
of bedrooms and a house and other things
so
we chose that
i would tell you personally i am not
hung up on it but i wanted to be able to
provide
to this body
a definition that would allow us to have
at least a stake in the ground
the other thing as i'm here at the mic
that i did want to also add that i
didn't include in my testimony is that
one of the most important things that
came out of the car seat school as well
as a personal interview with judge
ashley is that our legislat our judges
in family court are actually asking us
for more prescription
they feel like there is a lack of
continuity between our courthouses on
judgments
so the recommendation in this bill is an
exact representation of the vermont
calculations that have been in practice
for over a decade and they're the
closest as far as demographics to new
hampshire as far as using
child support laws so again thank you
and if are there any other questions
are there any other questions you may
have a follow-up madam chair follow up
thank you um miss town uh with regard to
the car seat school is in your testimony
that um i just got here at the desk
um
in your second paragraph you're talking
about uh a study that was performed is
that what you're referencing
the cause is that the study you're
talking about awesome so we can just go
to their website excellent well it's
actually posted on our own dhhs website
great um so there had been a minor error
in one of the exhibits they updated and
refreshed it it's been there for two
years and we have it there as part of
our federal requirements for managing
our child support process
thank you so much for the clarification
thank you thank you thank you for being
here thank you okay any further
questions
all right seeing none thank you very
much
up next is representative yokela
and he's asked for five minutes
thank you madam chair members of the
committee
i have pat i believe has been passed
around an amendment to this bill
if not it should be coming your way
and um
there's also some examples of
um of what i'm proposing the new child
child support worksheet might look like
so that you would be able to fill it in
yourself and would have a few examples
um and that looks like it's being passed
around now
and
so
the amendment that i have drafted
um was is it trying to address some of
the things that the senate had an issue
with which was clarity
they didn't they felt that the um the
calculation was too
complicated for them to understand and
so
some of the
parts of the formula have been broken
down in smaller parts so that it's more
clear and readily understandable and so
each in the examples of
1 through 13 14
each one of those
is now
defined as part of the amendment and so
that you can understand how those
calculations are done and they they
conform to the
subtraction and addition and
multiplication that is that is uh
suggested on this worksheet
and so
what i'm trying to do
is
kind of trying to take a step back and
say what is child support
child support is
what we are
making sure that each family
is spending on the raising of their
child um each person is contributing to
the raising of their child and one part
of contributing to raising your child is
actually housing them
and um another is a financial aspect and
so
it's not always the case that those are
handled by the same person and so we're
trying to make it so that those people
are are you know if they make 75 of the
money they're contributing 75 percent of
the
the um financial responsibility and if
they're getting if they're housing the
kid you know 50 of the time or 25 of the
time that they're getting credit for
doing that parenting in the calculation
and that is the basis of my amendment
and i'm happy to walk through it if you
guys want but i i hope that it will be
as clear as i tried to make it
and so
with that i will be happy to take any
questions
are there any questions for
representative yokela
oh
did you want to say something else yeah
oh go ahead so
um so a couple of other things
sorry that i um forgot to mention inside
of the amendment is a change to the um
self-support reserve
we were suggested by this carson study
to just do a modest increase from
115 to 120 of the federal poverty
um line which would only leave people
on the lowest end with about sixteen
thousand dollars a year
and so it was
discussed that that
really isn't
enough to be able to live in new
hampshire and so um it was
uh amended to instead be a hundred and
fifty percent of the reserve so that
would be just over two twenty thousand
dollars to be able to live on so that
the that these child support orders are
not putting people in in the position of
being homeless in new hampshire
okay are there any questions for
representative yokela thank you
representative all chiller
thank you madam chair
thank you for this very detailed
amendment i think i might have more
questions for you
during their executive session but at
the moment
um
was there
the definitions your your change is just
to one is to add 1b
is that correct
could you repeat it i couldn't really on
page one of your amendment okay your the
only change
to rsa 458 c2 would be to add in
paragraph 1b
that's that's an addition
yes that's additional language right yes
the bold on line 17 through 21 is
additional um everything above that is
the same
so it's just kind of breaking it out
into a another step of the formula so
you have gross pro
gross income then adjusted gross income
and then you get to
another adjustment which was already put
in law i was just breaking them out into
smaller pieces so that people would
understand
what is the math that is happening at
each step
so that anyone should be able to follow
this
may i follow up madam chair
so um
could you explain uh because i i don't
understand the verbiage on page three
line eighteen
um i'm i'm struggling with child support
obligation calculation means
the parent's household responsibility
minus the parent's financial
responsibility
what is the differentiation between
financial household
and financial responsibility thank you
for the question yeah thank you i
there is
so those
um phrases are terms of art right that
are also defined inside the statute so
um child
parents household responsibility if you
look down on 20 to 21 it says parents
household responsibility means the
parents household responsibility
percentage
like the percentage of the household
responsibility that they have multiplied
by
the
total support obligation and the total
support obligation is defined somewhere
else as
the amount that needs to be
um contributed to the child for raising
the child per year so if it's you know
twenty thousand dollars that we need to
be paid paying to raise a child and you
parent that you have the household fifty
percent of the time then we would assume
that you are contributing to the raising
of that child for
fifty percent of twenty thousand which
would be uh ten thousand right
okay could you follow up may i follow up
um
perhaps i need to look in statute if you
if we're
if if you look at um the example
worksheet do you have that one
with the example
worksheet like a four four page thing of
examples
yes sir got it
beautiful
so um
so household responsibility percentage
is found in the parenting plan
right it's going to tell you how often
you're supposed to have the kids
and
and that's going to be based off of the
best interests of the child as we've
we've um hammered home a million times
and and uh changed the statute to
reflect pretty much everywhere um the
parenting plan is going to be based on
the best interest of the child and then
work on that that's on line 11 and so to
get the household responsibility we're
going to multiply line eight which is
the total support resp uh obligation
times 11 which will get you your amount
so there are some examples of amounts um
on
the subsequent pages so that you would
be able to
follow hopefully
thank you i think i need a little time
to digest but absolutely
are there any further questions
all right
seeing none thank you very much thank
you okay we're running short on time so
i'm keeping people to the time they
wrote on their card
so up next is vivre and gerard to speak
in opposition to the bill and she does
have written testimony
thank you madam chair and members of the
committee
again my name is vivian gerard and i am
the silva beast silva case
and
thank you for letting me come here today
to speak
and i wanted to make sure that you guys
understand that by passing this bill
this undercuts everything that i've
worked so hard to accomplish
as i had said previously in my testimony
i have
primary residential for the children
i was a stay-at-home mom for 13 years
with my children
my daughter has a disability we opened
up a family-owned business
so i could stay home and raise my
children
and care for my elderly parents
and
the silva v silva case
came up because of
a lot of the child support calculators
that they they've been trying to use
just did not fit for me
and by having a stay-at-home business
there was we had to find a way
in order to maintain two households
maintain normalcy for my children keep
them in the same house that they grew up
in keep them in the same school system
allow me to operate my stay-at-home
business my at-home business if i get
forced out of my house i am un
unemployed not underemployed but
essentially
unemployed
these child support calculators should
not be this difficult
again as i had mentioned earlier it
would be great if
there was different calculators to fit
different lifestyles
one calculator will not be the same for
everybody
again if you use it as similar to a flow
chart as they do in companies if
somebody's married for 20 years
at home business stay-at-home mom
they're staying in the family home in
order to keep the children in the same
school system and he goes off to another
town with his girlfriend and living in
another town
why should i not be able to keep my
children in the same household the same
school system
by
undercutting the silva v silva case
you're you're essentially doing that
you're going to force us out of the
household or force us to rely more on
the taxpayers to bear that burden that
somebody of a hundred and fifty thousand
dollars should be able to make
and and and take that money and give it
to the family
if somebody decides that they want to
move on in a different direction
why should the family suffer for
somebody that can't keep his pants on
realistically again you know we have a
family owned business
and
the judge at the time
said that my
employment
was under employment because i was not
making
as much as
i i did 15 years prior 15 years prior
i was a buyer
high-tech company
i can't go step foot in in a purchasing
position after 15 years i lost all my
skills i purchased this home so i could
have a stay-at-home business
and i put every cent i had into this
built building and and into my home
in order to maintain
what we were supposed to do before the
divorce
so my life never got preserved by these
judges my financial stability got never
never got preserved
my
kids
family dynamics
if i take them out of that household
that will not be preserved
so
again
this is what happens when you have
22 hearings
five supreme court appeals
this is all the problems that i'm still
trying to resolve
and at this point as i had mentioned to
you guys before
i do not support this bill
because as of right now
uh by giving
judges these calculators again it does
not fit every lifestyle
and even with the silva v silva case
these judges aren't even being held
to
any standards that they even have to
follow the laws
here i am seven years later and they
still have not
resolved the silva v silva case
so my children had to sacrifice over all
these years for things that they should
have had that that were easy
you know most kids have braces
medical
food on their plate
vacations
activities my kids did not have any of
that growing up they get it with their
father
because he makes so much more than i do
and here i am seven years later and i'm
still struggling to maintain a household
for my children
the mortgages don't go down you have to
keep going quickly okay
okay
and and realistically utilities and
everything else do not go down so even
if you give one parent a certain
calculator it doesn't help keep them in
that same household
so
this is not just
a law
this is my life
this is what i had to live the last
seven years so by going ahead and
approving something without looking at
all the different reasons for it you're
just going to keep creating more appeals
and more court hearings
and more strain on families and and
these families that are going through
this the pain is real
so i would like for you to consider that
as you're going ahead and approve in
this bill
as well as many other bills because this
is not a game this is our life and then
in three years we go back and revisit it
we're going to be right back to where we
are now
okay thank you and i would like to
assure you that no one up here thinks
it's a game well okay
again i've been living this and i'm back
and forth every i understand but i just
wanted to clarify that not one person at
this table thinks this is a game thank
you i appreciate that thank you
up next is michael dinan and he's asked
for 10 minutes and i ask if maybe you
can go a little quicker than that
because we're really behind
if you just want to hand it and they'll
pass it out okay
yeah they'll just pass it around thank
you
good morning madam chair and members of
the committee thanks for having me speak
um i'm in support of hp 1647 i want to
keep it clear and hopefully very brief
um
speaking about when i've passed this all
out it can all be read as well i want to
cover the calculations there's always
this matter of confusion when these
things come up and it just came up with
josh
ukele as well
if i want to look at this simply and i'm
not a math major or anything like that
you take both um the percentage that is
attributed which let's say as an example
for two children is 25 percent if the
higher earner makes 60 000 as an example
the lower earner makes 30 000 you
combine those what is 26 percent of that
let's just call it 25 it's 22 000
of is 26
if the lower earner um
is responsible for a third of that
then the higher earner is responsible
for two thirds of that
that lower earner
excuse me the higher earner would pay
the difference to the lower earner it's
that simple it's very clear it's not
ambiguous it provides a very clear
language for judges for people that are
pro se such as myself representing
myself and also the rest of the uh
of the state so i just want to read
through this quickly to touch on many of
the points some of this will be staring
at what you've heard already uh
current state of guidelines is perverse
and detrimental to new hampshire i'm
going to ask you not to read your
testimony okay because we have it
just point out some of the highlights of
it because we will read it understood
since silva v silva in 2018 november of
2018 and if you look at the back of what
you've been handed out you can look at
the calculations if the lower earner
makes a dollar less than the higher
earner or even just a dollar annually
meaning no job they receive roughly the
same amount of income
from the the higher earner this is not
make believe this is what happens all
the cases anderson b anderson which
abrami had mentioned
states the same thing all of the funds
go to the lower earner the funds that
are intended as an example the 26
percent was meant to be shared across
two households in the case in sylvie
silva which is precedent and now
actually anderson v anderson's become
precedent as well
all the funds go to the owner lower
earner the higher earners left sometimes
in an indigent state
meaning that people that have a low
income already if they're not having the
day-to-day funds to pay for their
children's
everyday fixed costs being put a roof
over their head they are left with
nothing this is not imagination
the car she school says the same the
dartmouth study and you can see it in
there and i cite it and there are links
it's not an active document but you can
look at what the national um
family council gave to the state and f
and this isn't some like
you know perception thing this is a
reality we're third highest in the whole
country
so some people and have been speaking
today about their personal cases
in fact it's the silva v silva that has
gone back and forth with the supreme
court but that precedent states it's
called starry decisis it will not be
changed and yes i would admit that that
vivian has had
her case lowered they keep lowering it
back to the original amount then it gets
passed back up to the supreme court what
it's about is the language that is in
our current guidelines it's very clear
that it says
equal or approximately equal parenting
time is not grounds for deviation add
that to the fixed cost points that
everyone else has pointed out today and
you have this disastrous scenario that
again
it's 70 or greater that have happened
since 2018 and if they haven't suffered
it they're going to be coming up for
their three-year re-up and revisitation
to their guidelines that everyone will
be suffering this everyone's going to be
going through this so wanted to talk
about what about the legislation the
previous attempts to have legislation go
through that were scrutinized because of
the the factors that that brenda had
brought up as well these factors are you
know that it's going to be catastrophic
to our courts well they're already
overwhelmed because of of silva v silva
that amount can be weight you know it
can be said to be enacted in 2023 or or
before the three years which everyone
has got to revisit their their um
calculations that the the calculations
are confusing and yes they are what this
bill does 1647 is provides an easy
prescription for everyone to follow to
understand it allows for deviations
based on certain criteria but it does
not create this wild west environment
that happens when everyone goes into
court
and i've suffered it and everyone else
is beginning to stop for this so if you
read through my testimony if you get a
chance you look at the numbers in the
back which is clearly showing someone
makes a dollar versus the the higher
earner someone makes nothing it causes
the lower earner to intentionally be
underemployed
what the current guidelines do and
there's some other
bills that are being looked at right now
and in the other bills too it does the
same thing okay let's stick to this bill
because we're really short on time
so if you look at the language in 1647
it does provide for exceptions it does
provide a very clear
non-ambiguous non-um
subjective because a lot of the stuff is
subjective
so it it's very
straightforward if you look at the
higher earner the lower earner it allows
you to figure it out i just did that
math in my head this isn't something
that's complex but what it would do is
save new hampshire families just want to
make the critical point besides all this
math and calculations
in my case i am left with not enough
funds to even pay for my home because
the full child support amount goes to
the lower earner in that case they are
provided with a kind of lavish lifestyle
that prevents them from wanting to get a
job if they put in a if you put in a
um
you know a parenting amount based on
parenting time it's the only way to
establish it in my case i have the more
than 50 of the time but that doesn't
matter i still pay the full amount and
in the case of of what 1647 would do it
would take reality into to account i
want to make something clear parenting
plans are established before
the child support guidelines are
established so every time without
ambiguity they're established first so
you can't in some special interest
parties want to say well you can't put
parenting time based on the financial
obligation of the parents
well
it it actually is decided beforehand
there's no way to associate the two and
that guides that misunderstanding of how
the law works has been misused by many
people when talking about these bills so
i don't need to go any further but would
like to answer any questions um and i
think if you could take a glance at the
testimony the grades the car seat school
study the dartmouth school study
everybody agrees just how to go about it
how do we make that change 1647 is the
most effective it is fair it gets us
back to reality
grateful and does anyone have any
questions okay does anyone have any
questions
seeing none thank you very much thank
you very much
up next is richard head to speak for
three minutes just for informational
purposes
three minutes mr head thank you um thank
you madam chair members of the committee
my name is richard head i'm the
government affairs coordinator for the
judicial branch i have one very
specific point i would like to make
regarding the bill is drafted which is
it has no applicability clause
so you've heard about the
the potential impact on caseloads in the
in the circuit court and again when i'm
talking circuit court i'm talking family
division probate division and
district and all of those are being
impacted by various bills but this
particular bill
has the potential to have a significant
impact on the circuit courts as it
relates to family division in that it
the lack of a of an applicability clause
means it applies to all existing orders
and i'll point out that the last time
this section was changed which was uh in
a 2012 bill
that
bill being uncoordinated house bill 597
in 2012
had a very specific applicability clause
which said it shall not apply to a valid
child support order in effect on the
effective date of this act until the
next scheduled review hearing so it did
allow for ultimately the the new
provisions to be
to be applied
but it avoids that rush to the
courthouse and that's the the primary
point that i wanted to bring out we do
very specifically ask no matter whether
it's representative yokela's amendment
or or some other version that there be
an applicability clause in order that we
can have some level of control
over the hearings that are going to come
to the circuit court i'm sorry can you
just repeat what that bill was when you
yep absolutely and the year was 2012.
so the 2012
bill
get my fingers to work again
house bill 597
thank you
the only other
point i'll
briefly make is
that the the fact that this is tied
um to parenting time could result in a
delay of child support orders or
multiple revisions of child support
orders as the parenting time is
determined in stages
so it just adds to the potential for
litigation the the sort of tied to
parenting time very specifically
creates a scenario where there's likely
to be a new area of an adversarial
relationship of the parties and i do you
know we are concerned anytime there's an
increase in the potential of an
adversarial relationship in family
division
has a negative impact on the overall
outcomes of those cases so i do just
point out that that tie at least raises
some concerns of a potential area of
adversarial relationships because it
then becomes very specifically tied to
child support and with that i'd be happy
to answer any questions are there any
questions for mr head
representative altzerler
thank you madam chair and thank you mr
head for taking my question
with regards to what you the last
statement you just made about tying um
these formulas to parenting time and my
i had a question before that
um that's defined as overnights
and
is there i recall that we had some
discussions about what the term
overnights
meant and
when does overnight begin
like how is that deter what how is that
a legal definition so
um and i i don't know the answer i did
not specifically research that ahead of
time i don't believe it's defined in
statute and and i've now looked it up in
terms of the case law
any further questions no thank you
thank you very much thank you okay so
i'm going to close the um public hearing
on house bill 1647
and we'll come back in 10 minutes i
apologize that we're starting late but
everybody needs a little break
okay
is
actually
oh
okay
free
foreign
let's possible
is
so
this
somebody
just
so
foreign
right
ah
foreign
so
yes
uh
okay
what's up
so
there was an accident
yes
foreign
music
so
okay folks it's 11 o'clock
and i apologize it's 11 o'clock i'm
going to open the public hearing on 14
31 and i'm sorry
that we're running late so
i will call representative paul terry to
introduce his bill and he needs five
minutes
i'm out of chair that's approximately
but i certainly hope that it will be
about five minutes
madam chair honorable colleagues and
members of the committee i'm
representative paul terry representing
alton and gilmanton and i'm here this
morning to speak to hb 1431
the bill i have introduced
that if enacted
will provide new hampshire parents with
an expressed enumeration of rights with
reference to their minor children
this bill is but the latest expression
of a deeply rooted and treasured
national legacy that has
made the respect for individual rights a
bedrock principle and commitment of our
american republic
indeed as you will recall at the very
founding of our nation we declared
we hold these truths to be self-evident
that all men are created equal that they
are endowed by their creator with
certain unalienable rights
and in the very next sentence it is
further declared that to secure these
rights
governments are instituted
to secure the rights
please note that the role of government
and of each one of us as elected
representatives of the people and
legislators is to secure rights that may
be otherwise threatened by accident or
design
not long after our national constitution
was ratified it became clear to a
majority that it ought to be amended to
secure certain individual rights
the first ten amendments
ratified and made effective december 15
1791 have become known by generations
of american school children as the bill
of rights
through the ensuing decades we have
striven to form a more perfect union
often doing so by enacting
new laws that we have come to believe
are securing even more individual rights
and freedoms
one such example
of a more recently recognized and
enacted law is our state's patience
bill of rights and responsibilities
a copy of which
i am holding before you in my hand
it was enacted in 1981
and has since been amended several times
we in new hampshire enjoy a uniform set
of rights and responsibilities that
people can know
utilize and rely upon whenever and
wherever we may be admitted to a health
care treatment facility in 1981 we came
to realize that we needed such a law and
i believe the time has come in 2022 to
recognize that we now need a parent's
bill of rights
to make clear the will of the people of
this state
that parents have certain unalienable
rights with respect to the care of their
minor children
particularly and especially with respect
to their educations and health care
these historic rights that have been
acknowledged across many cultures the
world around
have more recently come under grave
threat in our country
hence the need to redress the imbalances
and outright expressions of obstruction
and refusal to honor once what was once
viewed and honored for the most part as
an established and integral role
for parents
a rhode island mom's request to view the
curriculum that was being used to
instruct her child was refused by her
district school committee both the
school committee and then the teachers
union retaliated with lawsuits against
her
in virginia legions of moms throughout
the state joined together to fight back
against school boards that refused
to disclose curriculum being used in
their the parents schools
and in washington state
recently two bills were enacted into law
such that when taken together they will
prevent parents from refusing gender
reassignment surgery to their children
as young as 13
should the child decide to change gender
the
child national council of state
legislatures has reported to me that 11
state legislatures are considering
parents bills of rights in 2022
including our own
10 states already have laws on their
books
both democrat and republican-controlled
states
the bill before you
h.b 1431 is modeled after florida's law
we have an amended version of hp 1431
that provides an enforcement section
and a precise copy of the parent's bill
of rights
that we propose be provided to every
parent at the beginning of each school
year throughout the state
the latter comes to us courtesy of
education committee chair representative
ladd
thanks to the work of education
committee vice chair representative
glenn cordelli it has been modified to
include helpful references to certain
existing rsas
each of you will receive the amended
version of this bill
0546-h at the conclusion
or actually at this time of my testimony
enacting hp 1431 and its amendments will
ensure
that every new hampshire parent of a
minor child will enjoy the same rights
regardless of county or community
with parents encouraging more and more
encountering more and more difficulties
in their attempts to provide primary
guidance decisions for their children's
education and medical treatment it is
imperative
that we act this year for them
for their children and for all of us
it
is
time
i'd be pleased to respond to any
questions that you may have
and if i am unable to provide an answer
now
perhaps one of the others here today may
be able to do so
if not i will do my best to find the
answer and get back to you thank you
for your consideration
thank you very much so i have a quick
question
on
in your amended version
on page three
hold on i'm trying to find it
um
the right of a parent
participate in parent-teacher
associations and organizations that are
sanctioned by a school board or the
department of education
um is that referring to like a pta or
a pto what what is that referring to
yes that's how i would interpret that
madam chair
so by saying um that that any parent can
is there
an exception in here anywhere for sex
offenders
no not that i'm aware of thank you
are there any other questions
representative petrigno
thank you madam chair and thank you
representative for taking my question
i'm looking at the bill
and
many of the enumerated rights as far as
i can see
exist in state law or are a matter of
many school district policies but the
one that i'm focused on
is
the right of a parent to exempt his or
her minor child from immunizations now
would that be
beyond the current exemptions for
medical and religious reasons
uh i'm not aware of uh of what the
answer to that question would be i don't
know i don't know okay thank you but
what it does sir is it codifies this
within this particular law
so that it's right there for anyone who
is seeking to know what all of the
rights are
uh it may be pursuant to another rsa and
if in fact it is
then we have missed it so far and
hopefully in your work session you'll
pick it up thank you may i have a quick
follow-up madam chair follow up okay so
the reason for my question
is because uh many uh medical experts
pediatricians and so forth would
recommend immunizations as we currently
have them for polio chicken parks dip
the area so forth and so on and there's
part of this legislation that goes on to
say that this section does not authorize
a parent of a minor child
in this state to engage in any conduct
that may be neglectful to the minor
child would you say that not
immuno-immunizing children going into
school would be
neglectful and if that's the case
wouldn't those two parts of this
legislation avoid
one another
personally i view that as a very
personal decision and an individual
right
that view may not be shared by all
thank you representatives
representative desimone
thank you madam chair thank you
representative for taking my question
um
is there an exception in here
anywhere that i can't find
for protective orders
not that i'm aware of
in your work session you may want to
consider such an addition
thank you representative no further
questions
representative long
thank you madam chair thank you
representative
with reviewing this i
i noticed a lot of the language is
singular and this this committee knows
all too well when both parents don't
agree
on something so how
how does this reflect on if one parent
is in favor of something which gives
them their right and the other parent
has that same right but opposed to it is
there any language in here that
identifies that scenario i mean this
this bill assumes that both parents are
are on the same page
and this committee finds that
that's not often the case
so so is there
something that
both parents will have that right
and how does that work
uh this is just off the top of my head
but i would say that
that's something that would have to be
interpreted and adjudicated unless it's
actually specified within the statute i
don't know what florida's experience has
been with respect to the singular plural
question that you are posing
to the best of my knowledge
there has been no challenge to that law
based on the question that you have
asked
good question okay and i hope the
committee will consider that
in its uh in its deliberations on on the
language of this bill okay thank you
welcome
representative all shiller
thank you madam chair and thank you
representative terry for taking my
question
um i think i'm on the i'm i'm on the
original bill
if there is a change in my in the
with what my question is then i'll go to
the amendment
but i'm looking at page five at the end
parental consent for health care
services
my first question and i would like a
follow-up is ex is on is lines eight
through ten except as otherwise provided
by law
or a court order a health care provider
may not allow a medical procedure to be
performed on a minor child in its
facility without first obtaining
written parental consent is
i mean we often look at bills and
in this committee with with an eye
towards fixing problems is there a
problem in new hampshire with
health care providers
doing medical procedures on children
without their parents knowing about it
and how are they how are they paying for
that
how is that how is that manifesting in
new hampshire that we need to put that
in statute
i believe that there are others who can
speak to that question specifically but
i am aware
broadly speaking that the answer to your
question is yes
and by containing this language we would
seek to preempt any future problems
but your aunt the answer to your
question is yes and i believe one of the
uh representatives who will speak
subsequently um
can answer that question and if he does
not in his testimony please be sure to
raise that question again with him
and he'll give you specifics thank you
for your question
i may have a follow-up madam chair
follow-up
back on that exact
on that section parental consent
in the first section one except as
otherwise provided by law
a health care practitioner or an
individual employed by such health care
practitioner
may not provide
or solicit or arrange to provide health
care services or prescribe medicinal
drugs to a minor child without first
obtaining written parental consent so
under the provide solicit
are you saying that for instance in
high schools and libraries and other
places where
young people congregate and public
health officials want to get information
to them about health care services and
how to keep themselves
safe and healthy
that we would not be able to put up
posters that would tell
students about their ability to access
certain health
health care on their own
first of all
is that what that's trying to do
thank you for your question first i'm
not sure exactly where you are
um i'm not hearing you clearly page five
line six page five yep line six
a school employee that is not a teacher
in the original bill on the original
bill i'm sorry um i do not have the
original bill in front of me right now
but listening to your question
i think the question that i'm hearing
was framed in terms of consent
and you're asking about the providing of
information
so there is a clear distinction between
providing information and giving consent
and if if the language to which you are
referencing is about providing consent
then that that's different than
providing in for public health
information
which is fine
i'm all for providing any kind of
information and then
each parent
can contest that with respect to its
truthfulness and it's applicability
to that
parents or parents child or children
thank you for your answers
you're welcome
so i have one more question
um
in in on your amendment on page three
line 20 the right of a parent to enroll
his or her minor child in gifted or
special education programs if the child
qualifies for such programs
would it be the school that determines
that they're qualified
and and if so if the school doesn't have
a gifted program in new hampshire we
have a lot of small schools
uh
what would they be forced to provide
transportation to another district for
that child to enroll in a gifted program
that's an interesting question and if i
was the person who was interpreting this
law this bill if it would be enacted
into law
i would i would interpret this in such a
way is to say
that the school district in and of
itself
is not required to provide that program
but to find a way to provide that
program to that child even if it meant
having the child participate in that
program in a neighboring district which
is incidentally what happened with my
own
son
when he
was
still
in middle school
the
school was unable to provide the
particular program for him
it was called a gifted program at the
time and so the school had to find
a place where he could receive
the
accelerated or whatever it was called
education elsewhere
thank you
representative belanger
thank you madam chair and thank you
representative terry for bringing this
bill forward and presenting to this
committee today
so
on the first page
line
of the amendment thank you
uh line
four through five it says the state
excuse me all parents rights are
reserved to the
parent of a minor in the state without
obstruction or interference from the
state
would you say that also would include
dcyf
so representative you are you're
referring
you're referencing the language all
parental rights are reserved to the
parent of a minor minor child in this
state without obstruction or
interference from the state
yes and you're asking does the state
include dcyf that's correct
the way i read the sentence sir is that
all parental rights are reserved to the
parent
without obstruction or interference from
the state
now if subsequently a child is taken
from
by court action is taken from his or her
parent or parents home
then
the responsibility is
is necessarily transferred to the state
agency or the entity that has assumed
at least temporary supervision of the
child
that's how i'd interpret that
follow-up matter i should have been a
judge follow-up
thank you and thank you
thank you for responding so that's not
the way that i would interpret that
the way that i would okay we're going to
have a question not a debate if you're a
patient madam chair i'll get to my
question
um
so
that's not the way that i read it so
if you go into the next page of the
amendment on page 2 section 20-25
it states that a parent of a minor child
in the state has inalienable rights that
are more comprehensive than those listed
in this section unless such rights have
been legally waived or terminated
this chapter does not prescribe all
rights to a parent of a minor child in
this state unless required by law the
patient excuse me the rights of a parent
of a minor child in this state may not
be limited to or denied this chapter may
not be construct construed to apply to a
parental action or decision that would
end in life
so
i see conflicts
with this section
and
the the um the rights to
remove a child from care do you not see
those
concerns in that in between those two
sections i appreciate your
your concern i appreciate your question
i appreciate your
desire for for clarity or
the desire to eliminate ambiguity or
conflict
but as i read section four on page two
and i read section one on page one i see
no
i don't see any conflict at this time
but rather that
section one is interpreted
by the more specific language in section
four on page two
so i don't see that conflict i'll have
to really take a look at that and
consider more seriously what you're
saying and i hope your committee will as
well thank you
are there any further questions
representative gabois
what's gabby's last name
oh my god representative grossman and
i'll remember it someday this year
i'm so sorry
thank you madam chair
thank you representative for being here
and for presenting this bill
i do have a question on your amendment
if you could explain to me
line 11
what do you mean by condone authorize
approve or apply to a parental action or
decision that would end life
page two i'm sorry so i'm on page excuse
me representative i'm sorry thank you
for your question uh but i'm confused
i'm on line 11 of the bill on page one
and i'm not reading the same thing that
you are so on the amendment page two
you want to go to page two
okay
yep yes yes ma'am
um
this section does not condone authorize
approve or apply to a parental action or
decision
that would end life
what is this referring to
that section
in that particular item
2b is exclusionary
and therefore
[Music]
the the what is covered in this
particular section of the bill
it does not apply with respect to
section
2 a b and c
if you're asking what what is meant by
ending life uh that that that is a
question
that is subject to interpretation
once the law is passed unless there is
further elaboration and explanation by
what is meant by end of life
and that's the committee's job
with all due respect
follow-up
i'm not here to debate abortion
she has a right to ask questions
well certainly
i was concluding my answer
is that permitted ma'am
i wanted to conclude my answer i i
thought of something additional to say
before someone else was recognized thank
you i appreciate it you can follow up
you actually answered my follow-up
question i was um
asking what
would end life is that referring to a
child or is that referring to abortion
so you answered my question thank you
very much or
the child
i i believe that the
plain meaning
of life would mean
a child
who is already existing
as a child
okay
thank you are there any further
questions representative desimone
thank you madam chair thank you for
taking my question this is a follow-up
to
madam chair's question
on
page two
concerning
the
gifted
children and
if a parent
chooses to
enroll their child in gifted programs
that are not
in their public school who pays the
tuition
for
the
gifted program school
so i would neces the starting point for
me if i was in a position as a school
administrator would be do we have a
gifted program if we don't have a gifted
program and the child qualifies for a
gifted program then we need to find a
gifted program for the child if the
gifted program that is found by the
school administration for the child
is one with which the parent disagrees
and wishes another gifted program
it seems to me since it would be the
school district that is paying for
the gifted child a program for that
child
that the decision as to which gifted
program and i would hope there'd be a
conversation here between the parent and
the school district that in fact it
would be a decision of the school
administration as to which gifted
program were to be offered because the
word here is not programs there's no
specification that the right extends to
the parent to choose one among many
that's how i read that i hope that's
helpful
thank you
i won't continue the questions thank you
representative yokela
thank you and thank you for taking my
question
in
kind of following along uh
representative grossman's line of
questioning um
uh the the phrase that would end life is
not restricted to type of life and so
there is um
there's a question about would this
um
i think i'm
uh
would
it be more clear as to not prohibit
things like fishing and stuff like um
things that may be
done on farms and stuff like that so
that parents would be able to
um teach their kids in the uh about
those activities
and and even participate in fishing and
the like thank you
thank you representative um i'm sorry um
i'm looking at section two this section
does not
reference was made to end life
and i'm not sure how you got to fishing
were you suggesting that that there
i'm suggesting that fishing can cause in
the end of the life of the fish
i'm sorry i'm i'm suggesting that
fishing can
cause the end of the life of the fish
and so therefore
is causing the end of the life
and therefore this phrase would you
believe is too broad and should be
um
i see so so what would be helpful uh by
what i think you're inferring
or decision that would end
the life of a child
whatever clarification you you believe
is is appropriate i'm just was asking if
the clarification you believe was
necessary thank you
yes
i would say you could
help you could be helpful here
to any who would have questions about
how to interpret this should this become
law
by including the phrase
or
modifying that phrase such that it would
read that would end
the life of a child
any further questions
representative altschiller
thank you madam chair my
final question um i'm looking at the
amendment representative
and um
two things specifically um i'm reading
through your amendment and
on page four lines 31-36
uh outline how a parent
who believes or claims that a violation
of any of the provisions in this
this chapter
may bring an action for objective relief
and go straight to superior court
and
so as a hypothetical i'm looking at page
three
lines three section d
and um
you know a parent who objects to having
any discussion about acquired immune
deficiency syndrome
um has a child in a senior english sing
a senior lit class and is reading angels
in america
um so now their child has been exposed
to reading about
acquired immune deficiency syndrome
and now the parent can su according to
this it looks like a parent can then
sue
the school board the district the sau
because their child was exposed to
angels in america
is that is that how we're to read this
that any of these violations mean that
any parent could just
whip straight to supreme court i mean to
superior court
thank you for your question um
it would be helpful if
we were at the lob and i could actually
spread this law out on the table the
amendment
you know i'm tossing papers here while
you're speaking
i think i'm following your question
fairly accurately
and i don't see that as
necessarily
as a necessary consequence
of adopting this language as it is
presented i i don't see that that would
require further i think discussion and
study
study and discussion excuse me
i'm sorry i don't unders
is that a follow-up follow-up i i don't
understand what you said
perhaps it's well it's just my distance
but
i'm sorry i would like to wait until
you're finished
you're saying you don't understand
i'm saying perhaps i can't hear you
because we're in this room that is
echoing i did not understand your answer
to my question that if a child who's
engaged in a 12th grade english class
reads
angels in america but their parents
don't want them to have any education
about acquired immune deficiency
syndrome as outlined in section d on
page three
it appears
that in section
by under violations part two that they
can then sue
the school board school district and sau
in superior court and i wonder i want to
know if that is
if that was considered and do you
understand that that is
that what the what the ramifications
might be for the saus and schools
well once again uh representative
thinking off the top of my head with
respect to a specific hypothetical
incident
that you are describing it would seem to
me
that the path of least resistance would
be
in conversation between the school
authority and the parents and the parent
expressing
that
the parent does not wish the child to
read that particular book about that
particular condition
that to avoid any unnecessary litigation
the easiest so the the easiest indicated
solution would be that the student would
be exempted from being required to read
that particular book that the parent
found offensive
for the reason that the parent specified
to the school authority
rather than to immediately litigate
without having a conversation
are you outside representative
altschiller
yes thank you are there any further
questions
seeing none thank you thank you madam
chair and members of the committee
up next is representative don johnson to
speak in support of the bill for five
minutes
thank you madam chair thank you
committee members
my don johnson belknap county three um
i
submitted um three packets to all of you
i hope you all got them
there's two of them
that i like to explain and why i support
this bill
is the diversity inclusion and the
gingerbread person
these two trainings
were done to our school district as a
whole staff training
it took me weeks to get copies of these
not only am i a parent in this school
district in my in laconia school
district but i am also a school board
member
it was horrifying to know that it took
me weeks
trying to get this information as to how
and what our teachers and staff were
being trained on
and to find out that this information is
what we're being taught to our teachers
to teach our kids
was horrifying to me this is these are
my children i gave birth to them
nobody else
and when someone tells me that in here
that no one is allowed to tell me if my
child identifies as a man or a woman or
other ones and they have no right
and they're saying that they cannot tell
me as a parent that's how my child's
feeling
how does that help a problem
that only makes a problem worse for the
child
and so when i saw that in this paperwork
i was horrified that that's what they
were teaching these teachers to tell my
kids that they don't have to talk to me
i gave birth to them i put food on their
table i put a roof over their head i cry
them this i
walk them to sleep when they've been
sick
no government has ever
and
will never
take my rights as a parent away if i
don't want my child to know something
that is my right if my child needs to be
taught
an educational piece that is not being
taught in the school i can do that
the school's
purpose
is to teach
science math
reading and social studies and when the
deficiency ratings in our school
districts are 67 percent on average when
you take reading math and science and
you average them out
67 deficient i'm sorry but that is
unacceptable on any level
and then within a couple weeks
sorry
within a couple months of this training
the last packet i handed out was put on
the office of school wellness website
on facebook
this is what they were posting on the
office of wellness
train
facebook page
it took parents
multiple times of contacting the
superintendent to have this removed it
went up on in approximately the
beginning of april and ended and they
finally removed it at the end of april
that is horrifying
i know of a student who sat through a
zoom class last year
when a teacher
had nothing to do
with the top with the subject they she
was teaching
incited a riot with the kids to go
protest somebody's home
she only did it as she said as a joke
but got the kids going wanting to go egg
the person's house and attack the people
little did they know the person they
were talking about
was
the parent of one of the child sitting
in her classroom
i was horrified
as a parent to hear that and i was also
horrified as a school board member
and when the complaint was made at the
school level and at the department of ed
and an investigation was done and
that's child has no idea what
repercussions this teacher got
nothing
so now that child believes doesn't
matter what you do consequences don't
have actions i'm sorry i don't know
about any about anybody anybody in this
room but when i teach my child there's a
consequence to everything you do it
could be good it could be bad but when
you do something that
hurts and it threatens somebody's life
and no adult is hold you accountable
that is disgraceful on every level
from the
department of ed to the school district
this child does not
feel that she was justified
to know what happened to this teacher
when she caused tried to cause a riot
and this person had to turn around and
have police
watch their home for two months
every hour because of the threats that
were made
through this teacher and throughout the
community and i'm sorry but it's
outrageous
and it is time to take back our rights
as parents and i will fight to the end
for that
i'll take any questions sorry i get
emotional
are there any questions for
representative johnson
representative litchfield
yes would you please speak to your two
handouts the gender red person and the
deij
would you could you do a
45 second synopsis of each please real
quick so on january 20th uh 20th or 21st
i can't remember 22nd sorry january 22nd
2021 the laconia school district
did an all-staff training with these two
handouts and they had facilitators
teaching this to our uh
all of our staff
exactly my question exactly why why was
this taught to us student uh staff
to teach our students
this these handouts are horrifying and
if you don't find them horrifying you've
got something wrong
are there any further questions
seeing none thank you
up next is david murphy
to speak in support of the bill and he's
asked for 10 minutes
good morning and thank you for letting
me speak to you
i am a father
oh i should say skip i often times go by
skip murphy and i live in guildford
i'm a father of two sons 35 and 36. i'm
a grandfather to a child that just
turned six
it's a little bit of a different story
i'm not just a grandfather i'm also his
parent
my youngest did a year's deployment in
afghanistan and when he came home he was
self-medicating because of severe ptsd
he took up with somebody who was also
self-medicating to use the euphemism
and
my grandson was born as a result of that
he had opiates in his blood system
he was diagnosed with fetal alcohol
syndrome he has a number of different
issues
i am invested in this bill of rights
normally my favorite question as a
political activist
is who is in charge what is the proper
role of government what is it supposed
to do
and what shouldn't it do
here
we don't know who is in charge
school board seemed and staff seem to be
believing that they are in charge of our
children
it is needed because they shouldn't be
even though
the proper rule of
gov the proper role of government is one
of my questions lately it's been
superseded by
follow the law
which i don't believe our school systems
are doing
he is now in kindergarten
and now he is subject to what is going
on
a little bit of history 12 years ago i
did i covered an event in moultonborough
in which there was much discussion in
the community where a bunch of activists
from dartmouth wanted to come in for a
weekend long program with the kids in
the mountain boroughs high school
the problem was that parents were
objecting that there were two different
sessions
that
they were not allowed to watch or
participate in and they said like a lot
of parents today
we are supposed to be in charge
not you
and one teacher stood up and said
you don't know what you're talking about
your kids know more than you do
because we've taught them that
that was the first time i ran into the
idea that teachers and staff are trying
to separate parents from their children
and they were very blatant about it and
it's only gotten worse
my daughter-in-law or soon-to-be
daughter-in-law
has a degree in special ed her
professors kept telling her
verbatim don't trust the parents
there's another slice at separating
children from parents
i can tell you a number of nationwide
stories as well
in buena vista
actually hold on to that just a second
the school boards
across the nation
are refusing to be held accountable to
parents
voters and taxpayers
i have a phrase for that as they sit in
their public meetings they act like they
are the easter island stow-faced
stone-faced moa statues
during public comment they refuse to
answer
they refuse to comment
and oftentimes
look rather disinterested yet these are
supposed to be our elected
representatives to be held accountable
according to article 8 of the new
hampshire constitution
responsible to us
freely accessible and transparent and
they refuse
the problem is
this is replicated not over not across
just districts here in new hampshire but
nationwide if you've been watching the
news which i hope that you have been
parents are in an uproar and uprising
against the school boards that
dismiss their complaints dismiss
their questions dismissed that they
should even be there at all
in fact here in my school district
they have a policy replicated across
other districts as well because they all
seem to come from the new hampshire
school board association
that if i had a problem i would have to
go to a teacher then to the principal
then to the superintendent
but there's no way in that policy to be
able to reach a school board
and yet here i was complaining about a
specific policy that they had just put
into place
my grandson was not in school at that
time
i had no way to access the school board
i had no way to get feedback
that's not right
this bill is needed in part because of
that
another policy that seems to be coming
in and where i really have most of my
problems
is policy jab again from the new
hampshire school board association
i am suing
the guilford school board over two
precepts in that policy
one it coerces speech
now policy jab is also called
transgender non-conforming students and
in it there is
a codicil that says a transgender
student has the right to be called by
their preferred name and pronouns
well let's translate that please
we are a dylan's right state no
subdivision of the state can do anything
that it wants unless you folks in the
new hampshire legislature legislature
has given them the power within the
state statute
so
where does this subdivision of the state
a school board
given the power
to grant a new right to a minor child to
coerce the speech of others
i have asked this for a year and a half
of my school board they sit there
stone-faced i have
entered in
rsa 91 right to no demands no answers i
email them no answers i go on knock on
doors no answers
they are completely unaccountable
because that is blatantly illegal not
only by the us constitution freedom of
speech but also article 22 and a little
bit of article 30 in the new hampshire
constitution and yet there's nothing i
can do except sue
then the worst thing which
representative terry brought up
lying to parents
there is a privacy part
where this this district has given
themselves the power to lie
by omission
or commission
to parents about the transgender student
the
transgender status of a student who
happens to be that parent's child they
will refuse to tell
that parent what is going on at the most
in
developmental age of a child
and to keep the parent away
sequestered from that information
and yet the parent is responsible if bad
things happen
my grandson suffers from a number of
different things
if he was to go transgender
i would never know
i would never know that he has problems
i would never know that this could
complicate the ones that he already has
but the staff feels good about
themselves
they've gone woke
and i'm happy to put it that way in
buena vista california there were two
teachers at a conference that boasted
about how they hid
their transgender clubs after school
from both parents and other staff
members with the staff kind of just
looked away
they
basically saw themselves as missionaries
they turned not more than a few peop
more than a few students to be
transgender
one parent finally found out about it by
accident
now that school board is being sued
12 imagine that 12 year old turns to
transgender and they won't tell the
parent even when asked they are
instructed use their birth name use
their birth sex or gender by the way
gender is just a more genteel way from
the victorian age of saying sex
the latest one that just came out was a
story out of georgia
where 12 year old was found hanging in
the bathroom on her second suicide
attempt
after the counselors in that school
system were counseling her oh you feel
like a boy you must be transgender
and the parents were never told
is this the kind of school system that
we need
and you look and say
yeah maybe a parent's bill of right so
that we get full information
from school boards that the parents are
in charge are there
school boards essentially believe that
all parents are guilty why else would
they lie again by commission or omission
to parents about certain things about
their children in school
they are acting like
they are in charge that they are the
parents
i'm sorry that's not the new hampshire
way
it's it's sad that this bill is even
needed
that we have to clarify
that the parents are supposed to be
preeminent in the raising of their
children and how they are educated
remember government is supposed to work
for us
we hire the teachers and the districts
to stand in our stead to raise them to
learn
reading writing arithmetic and all that
other stuff and yet when you look at the
standardized tests overall
new hampshire does very well
but the percentage of students that are
not proficient in those subjects
is rather poor
this bill is needed
what's needed even more is that this
bill is just a stepping stone to force
school boards to follow the law the laws
that are already on the books and not
take actions or give themselves the
power
to things that they are not entitled
because you folks have not given it to
them
i will tell you that not only being a
father and grandfather for full
disclosure
being a political activist i was on my
budget committee for almost 10 years
having to deal with the school board it
was not a fun situation by any means i
am also the co-founder and owner of
granitegrock.com
new hampshire's largest and most
influential political blog site
we have a rating that is well above all
the other print
media here in new hampshire our standing
is about eleven thousand
here in the us that a lower number is
better
union leader is thirty three thousand
the seacoast online is up forty thousand
we are one of the top 50 000 websites
here in i mean worldwide union leader is
about 130
all the others
pale by comparison that's just online
reach
i have a lot of readers
who target conservative activists
they are all upset about this so
by proximate proxy i am standing here
talking for them they want to know what
you are going to do
who are you going to choose
school boards
or them as parents it's an important
question it goes back to my original one
who is in
charge you folks get to decide that
thank you
and i am available for any questions
are there any questions
seeing none thank you thank you
up next is leanne romano to speak in
support of the bill she has a question
mark but i ask you to keep it brief
there's a lot of people signed up no
problem i'll try leanne romano
litchfield um
so i
i have to say i can't believe we're here
actually
having to have a bill
like this
i thought that the birth certificate
that has my husband's name and my name
was the documentation needed
for me to have my parental rights and
the fact that i have taken care of my
three children
and their
they're healthy
i really support this particular
bill because
it is beginning to be
the staff and teachers versus
the parents and the parents are not
looking to be enemies we're looking to
work with them
i have had a great relationship for 25
years with all my children and
litchfield teachers and the school board
and whatever
but it's
people are changing now people are
retiring they don't want to deal with
parents so on and so forth i get it
people can get really heated but we have
to have something in place that makes us
in charge i do not ever want to
ever see
that somebody accidentally vaccinated my
child because the name was similar like
i've seen i don't want to see somebody
else's child getting coaxed hey we'll
give you pizza just shh don't tell mommy
and daddy no
i've already expressed my concerns and
views
with the school board with the
superintendent they've assured me that
that's not going to happen
but
i see it happening out there not in my
school not with my kids because i'm on
it but what it you know what about the
parents that don't know
that they should be doing this and it
just because i send an email doesn't
mean
that
they're going to adhere to that
there has to be something in place that
says no we're not going to do this we're
not going to do that we're not going to
talk about that you have say in what is
the curriculum
i've asked the health teacher what's the
topics and she assured me what it was
and you know i
i went over it with her this is okay
that's not okay i'm getting messages
from teachers
this is the topic that we're going to be
talking about do you agree or disagree i
put my phone number in every email i
don't want just a signed paper i want
you to talk to me because my kid can
forge my signature and if i catch him
it's going to be a problem but
i mean i want to know what's going on we
should have something in place that
that is a collaboration amongst the
school the staff
and the parents
where we can work together to get things
in place and to go over the topics
i don't think it's it's the place of
anyone to go over someone's gender or
their mental health status we have
doctors i have counselors for my kids if
they need it i have doctors for vaccines
i don't like the the inference that
well what if what if parents are
neglecting their duties by not
immunizing or whatever i mean come on
all of our kids are vaccinated if
they're attending public schools
typically unless they have an exemption
i mean
we can discuss that with our own doctors
there's only one vaccine if it's
actually a vaccine
that is in question right now
really
um
i think you should support this bill
if you need to change whatever you need
to change you know to
make it fit whatever
fine we need rights parents need rights
we absolutely need to have a say in the
curriculum we should be concentrating on
their education not their social life
not their social status or their
activities or i mean it's great that
they have support staff
but
we can just infor
inform us that there's an issue and we
can take care of that on the side or
work with the school
always inform always inform the parents
we're not animals we're the ones that
birthed them please support the bill
are there any questions
seeing none thank you
up next is alicia houston she's asked
for three minutes to speak in support of
the bill
good morning
representatives and thank you for the
opportunity to speak
um
i am looking around this room and i'm
listening to the testimonies i was going
to write something down and then i
didn't so here i am in front of you
communication
and transparency
that's a lot of what this has to do with
the communication barrier that parents
are facing right now without this bill
in place
is astounding i can tell you from
specific experience i come from a city
that many representatives unfortunately
have left to eat itself
nashua
in nashua we have no rights as parents
i i've asked for curriculum information
to find out what is being taught to my
children
they will not disclose that i've sent in
91a a right to no request they will not
disclose that we've sent emails and
phone calls and more emails and more
phone calls we have been at this
relentlessly for two
years
i'm exhausted
i'm a tired mom trying to do what's best
for my children this parents bill of
rights would give me the opportunity to
make decisions autonomously as their
mother
and i know that earlier there had been a
question to one of the representatives
regarding the specifics on what if the
parents don't agree that's what the
court is for that's not what this bill
is for this bill is to give parents
their rights back we don't have rights
right now we have a school board that is
a dictatorship that makes the decisions
for our children
and another perfect example is i have a
child with a medical exemption for the
wearing of masks and the district won't
honor it
and i have nothing to fall back on they
have 194 colon 3.
i have nothing
so as a parent i'm stuck in this
situation like many other parents who
have had no voice we've been silenced
the school boards are running rampant
and it's not just the school boards it's
doctors it's counselors it's all of
these people who are making decisions or
implementing these coerced
mindsets into our children and i know i
sound like a conspiracy theorist but
what i want my children to know is what
i want my children to know
at the beginning of kovid we spent so
much time avoiding the news because i
have a child with severe anxiety and by
severe anxiety i mean he has panic
attacks i don't know if anybody's
experienced a panic attack but it is the
worst thing that you can experience from
a psychological standpoint you feel like
you're dying
so we made the decision as parents
to eliminate all of the additional media
because it was causing an adverse
reaction for our child
he returned to school eventually because
again nashua
he returned to school and within a week
one week
he came home hysterically crying visibly
upset he got off the bus and fell off
the bus as a parent put yourself in that
shoe
watch your child fall apart
because teachers had decided that they
were going to tell him that if you're
not vaccinated and you don't wear a mask
or if others that you love are not
vaccinated or not wearing a mask they
will die
that is what was told to my 12 year old
son
so not only do i not know what's being
curriculum taught but i also don't have
a say to question things
so i'm in support of this bill and i i
urge all of you to please
give us our parental rights back give us
something that is concrete and tangible
that we have as a backing just like
these school boards and these doctors
and these patient rights and prac like
everybody else has rights
ours have been muted
so i urge you to all please
support this bill
thank you
are there any questions
sorry
sorry hi go ahead representative yokela
thank you and thank you for taking my
question
in your experience at with nashua
have you
been
stuck in that circle
of um just going through administration
and not being able to
go to the courts to
have
it adjudicated that they need to be
giving you this information
so that's a really great question
representative
i'm a single mom
i work full-time i have two children i
have one with a disability
so
i have spent the last two years
going to the teacher going to the
administration going to the assistant
superintendent and then the
superintendent and i can't even get in
front of the board of education with an
appeal because there's no process and
they won't make an exception
so in order for me to take like legal
action
it's going to cost money it's going to
cost time that i don't necessarily have
to fight something that if i had a
parent's bill of rights i would have the
opportunity to combat it led from a
legislative perspective from a legal
perspective did that answer your
question
follow up
thank you um the proposed uh
suggestion in this bill seems to be to
take them to court
and so
um i'm wondering if in your example
this bill would help you if you're if um
the only recourse is to go to court and
you're not in a position to do that so
keep in mind that we don't have a
parent's bill of rights right now i
don't have any recourse so i'm stuck in
this vicious circle of going back and
forth and back and forth and even if i
go to court which we've tried we have
tried with injunctions
they fail we live again in a city that
has been left to eat itself
we have judges who
have
historically
ruled in favor of the city and we have
had zero breaks no breaks i'm not a
lawyer i can't afford to hire a lawyer
but if i had a parent's bill of rights
to answer your question representative i
would have been able to take that legal
option first
i wouldn't have been stuck in a hamster
wheel for the last two years
are there any further questions
seeing none thank you thank you
up next is alison dyer to speak in
support of the bill for three to four
minutes
hi allison dyer i am also from national
new hampshire and i am here in support
of this bill
i want to thank the sponsors of this
bill for bringing this forward because i
think i echo the sentiments of a lot of
people here today that
we feel like it's needed
and i also echo the fact that i'm sad
that we're here
it's a sad thing to have to legislate my
parental rights back because they've
been so eroded over the last you know
two plus years i mean the pandemic
itself certainly heightened it but you
know for the last decade or so we have
felt especially with regards to
schooling
that
we have been shut out
what's unfortunate is that we as parents
um
have been kind of viewed as uh
cooperative like unpaid functionaries um
or if we present even a mildly resistant
force were deemed threats to the system
and my children are mine and
i'm tired of being told that i am a
threat because my basic parental
instinct is to direct and protect my
child
and
i think what also the two years
with the pandemic has really highlighted
is that i always thought that the due
process clause of
our laws protected my my parental right
um and it does not matter how often i
bring it up whether it's
medical uh school things of that nature
you know i'm i'm told that it
doesn't apply and i'm not really sure
why it doesn't apply i thought it was
there in place to to take care of that
and
now we're in a place where we need this
bill of rights in order to
restore what i thought was already there
i mean uh the woman over there made
reference to the birth certificate
that's my child and
um
i'm having a hard time
before this hearing when it was
originally scheduled and rescheduled i
sat for a really long time and tried to
write something for this and i found it
really hard to do because
i'm really sad that we're here that we
need to be doing this but
we need to do this and and i can't
implore
you any more than
my
previous people have have said that it's
necessary it's needed and and
no government program can ever replace
or take
what
parents are there to do we we have to
support and love and care
these
kids they're the next generation of
humans and
it's not political it's not a culture
war i don't want to play political
parties i just want to be a parent
and like most good parents we're all
involved and we need to stay involved
and
i don't
want to continue to be schluffed off and
and not be able to be allowed to be
involved in the way that i feel
as the director of the children under my
care how i need to do that so again i i
support this bill i thank the
representatives for bringing it forward
i'm sad that we're here and i really
hope that you all see where we're coming
from
that it's not it's
for me
it's not political it's parental i'm a
parent
so thank you
are there any questions
representative long has a question
thank you madam chair uh yeah thank you
ma'am
to me it's obvious you're an involved
parent and i respect you for that
now you mentioned the last two years
it's been problematic
so can you go back four years
was it problematic
um i i've
personally have felt like it's been a
problem for at least a decade as we've
you know i'm a child of the 80s so
things i felt like were a lot different
i mean um the
my parents were in the school they were
you know in the doctor's appointments
with me and things like that and
probably about 10 years ago you know
when i was in my
early 20s um
i remember you know
if i wanted to bring my mother to a
doctor's appointment with me or things
like that they're like oh well you know
do you want to bring her in the room or
when i was uh going into my niece or my
nephew's school they were like oh you
have to wait here and you have to you
know go through a six-hour training to
be able to come into the classroom to
read a book i mean we used to just just
be able to sign up for that through the
school
you know uh you call the office and say
i'd like to come in and read to the to
the kindergarten nurse today or do a
craft give the teacher a break you know
and
it's all
we're just shut out from that and it
slowly progressed to where it is now
like for example like they said in
nashville we're not allowed in the
schools we can't volunteer they need
people and they won't take us
so
but i have noticed at least the last
decade or so it's changed where it's
just not as easy
to be involved because
we've kind of been pushed in this way
that you know other people are the
arbiters of our children
health and well-being and happiness and
that's just not the case
i'm that
okay thank you
any further questions
seeing none thank you
up next is representative jeff greeson
to speak in support of the bill and he's
asked for six minutes
thank you madam chair and members of the
committee i'm representative jeff
griesen of wentworth i represent the
eight towns of grafton county district
16. i'm honored to have worked with
representative terry in writing this
very important bill that is long overdue
long past 10 years ago go backing over
30 years ago
it's occurring with increased frequency
all around the country
the children are being exposed to
materials that their parents find
objectionable children are actively
encouraged and unable to do things
without their parents knowledge let
alone permission and children are
instructed to conceal things from their
parents
the people that are exposing children to
the offensive materials and encouraging
children to do things surreptitiously
and to conceal things from their parents
are the ch are the children's teachers
school counselors doctors legislators
and many others purporting to be
advocates of the well-being of children
but the supreme court has stated that
the interest of parents
in the care custody and control of their
children is perhaps the oldest and of
the recognized fundamental liberty
interests protected by the due process
clause of the 14th amendment
parents have fundamental liberty
interest in determining the care and
upbringing of their children and these
rights are inalienable and may not be
intruded upon absent a compelling state
interest
some of the questions that were asked
earlier of representative terry go to
this compelling state interest question
if there's no compelling state interest
the parents rights are supreme in the
case of the dispute between parents that
may disagree the state can then be
brought in to settle that dispute that's
what the courts are for but otherwise
this court stays out
and according to the u.s supreme court
the state's interest declines as the
life of the child nears ending this
means that the state can't interfere
with the parents decisions regarding
end-of-life decisions for their children
that goes to that one question about
what is life or something that's ending
life and it deals it pertains
specifically to end-of-life care for the
child and that's why the reasoning of
the supreme court
because of the primacy of the
relationship between children and their
parents it is the responsibility of the
state and all of its subordinate
entities to recognize promote and
respect the authority of parents over
their dependent children
except in cases when legal due process
supersedes parents are the supreme
authority over their children for
medical educational moral religious and
financial decisions and all other
aspects of the child's life no entity of
government or private sector should
enable promote encourage or permit any
behavior that undermines parental
authority
anyone who would undermine parental
authority destroys the family unit and
his anathema to civil society and the
rule of law
anyone who would expose children to
material so offensive that they cannot
be read publicly at a school board
meeting is not educating the children
but abusing them
anyone who would encourage a child or
enable a child or actively participate
in any activity along with the child and
then encourage that child to conceal
that activity from the child's parents
is a predator not a protector of
children
anyone who would allow this sort of
behavior to occur is actively breaking
the bond between child and his or her
parents turning the child against his or
her parents teaching the child not to
trust his or her parents causing the
child to believe that his or her parents
are the enemy or at best don't have the
child's best interest at heart but that
the person allowing them to engage in
this behavior cares more adolescence is
challenging enough as it is without
people who claim to love children
constantly driving a wedge between the
child and his or her parents especially
when that is the first relationship the
child ever had
the rights described in house bill 1431
are not rights given by government to
parents but rather confirms and affirms
these natural inalienable rights that
parents already possess so why is house
bill 1431 necessary when these are such
fundamental rights because these rights
are being violated on a regular basis
and with impunity
let me give you just a few examples one
that was mentioned earlier
states are allowed multiple states are
now allowing sex change operations
without parental permission or consent
and that's key without parental
permission or consent abortions without
a parental permission or consent
vaccinations without parental permission
or consent
an elementary school in denver colorado
posts on their web page the principles
that will guide their instruction during
school week in action this year and
these principles are from blm guiding
principles and one of these is labeled
black villages
and it's defined as the disruption
of western nuclear family dynamics and a
return to the collective village that
takes care of each other
all across the country students of all
ages are given surveys as part of the
social emotional learning model of
education these surveys are not for
academic achievement or instruction but
rather ask children about their
attitudes gender identities sex
practices and home lives
a substitute teacher was recently fired
for not recognizing a child's identity
as a cat and a school in michigan puts
litter boxes in the unisex bathrooms for
those children that identify as a cat
i am breaking the law
when i tell my grandson he's not really
a dinosaur because according to new
hampshire law if you counsel a boy that
he is not a girl or a girl that she is
not a boy
you are breaking the law because that's
considered conversion therapy we're
gonna have to expand that now to
dinosaurs and evidently cats
as
here in new hampshire there are two
bills presently before the house of
representatives that explicitly
are calling for children to be able to
act
without parental permission or consent
house bills 1409 and 1126 i don't care
what the bills are whether whether good
ideas are bad but they're designed to be
done without parental consent
or permission
or excuse me knowledge
this bill is necessary to clarify that
parents have authority over their
children at all times a teacher acting
in loco parentis does not supersede the
authority of parents and a doctor does
not have authority over a child patient
that supersedes the parents of that
child it doesn't take a village to raise
the children the village needs to
respect the parents and work at the
direction of the parents because
teachers are employees hired by parents
to educate the children not turn them
against the parents
doctors are hired by parents to provide
health care opinions
and recommendations
and then to provide the subsequent
medical treatments as directed by the
parents if a parent wants a second
opinion or rejects a particular
recommendation that is not child abuse
and the doctor has no authority to act
now we complain that social media
platforms don't do enough to protect
children from harmful content available
on those platforms and yet planned
parenthood sex education curriculum that
is pervasive across this country is so
sexually explicit that i would be gavel
down if i began reading the materials
here to you today
we demand that social media make sure
children aren't subscribing without
parental permission but we can allow a
teacher at school to take any age girl
down to the abortion clinic to obtain an
abortion without parental permission
children are suspended from school for
taking an aspirin without obtaining it
from the school nurse but we can allow
that same school nurse to take that same
child to a clinic to obtain and start
taking puberty blocking hormones without
informing the parents
house bill 1431 is of utmost importance
because the rights of parents are being
trampled to the detriment of children
including parents now being treated as
domestic terrorists for objecting to
anything being done in government
schools including their daughters being
raped in school bathrooms while the
school board conceals these rapes
while this bill explains what rights
parents have
this is one bill that truly is for the
children thank you
are there any questions
representative yokela
thank you and thank you for taking the
question
in new hampshire
we have
drug treatment programs which people
over the age of 13
can
access without parental
consent
would you be
um
one and
it's my understanding that they do that
so that those
treatments can be offered in such a case
that the
the kid not would not take advantage of
them
if they needed to tell their parents
that they were addicted to something
in your testimony would you
it seemed to me to be believe that you
would
not like that program to exist because
um without parental consent and those
peop those children that were addicted
to some substances and wanted some
treatment um
would not
accept that treatment if it was a
condition of telling their parents is
that
am i getting the
your position correctly i think we need
to get down to why does the child feel
like they don't they they can't get
their parents permission or talk to
their parents about their addiction
they have been they have been
conditioned for years now not to trust
their parents that if they if they want
to do anything whatever it is if their
parents say no we're gonna let you go
ahead and do it anyway
so we we've built this wedge of distrust
don't trust your parents your parents
are the enemy whatever the case may be
and so
does it if a child needs treatment
i can't think of a parent one who loves
their child that would deny the child
that kind of treatment
so it's it's it's a question of
where did this attitude of doing things
behind parents back we're not talking
about sneaking into a rated r movie
we're talking about life-altering
decisions there's a reason why we don't
have people under the age of 18 voting
god i hope we never change that
there's a reason why you have to be a
certain age to get a driver's license
there's a reason why i had to sign my
son's enlistment form so he could join
the united states marine corps before
the age of of 18. there's a reason why
we have these we're going to allow
children to make decisions and we're
specifically targeting all these things
you can do this behind your parents
backs that's wicked
so is that a no that the the program
should not exist
the the program itself can exist there's
nothing wrong with having a program like
that why are we purposely pushing it
that you can do this behind your parents
backs
representative long
thank you madam chair thank you
representative at the beginning of your
testimony
you put a perception in my head i need
to clarify if this were to become law
then
infringement on parental rights would be
also prohibited from the legislature
can you at the beginning of at the
beginning of your
testimony you referenced legislators
included in
prohibition legislators pushing
legislation like the two house bills
that i named specifically saying hey you
can do this without your parents
permission
so back to my original question if this
were to become statute
would
legislators be prohibited
from
infringing on parental rights
i seem to recall there being phrases in
the u.s constitution congress shall make
no law
et cetera et cetera et cetera infringing
on free speech freedom of assembly
right to keep and bear arms things like
that so no the legislature cannot pass
laws that would infringe on parental
rights these these are inalienable
rights the us constitution is going to
be the
the u.s supreme court has affirmed these
inalienable rights of parents
so no we can't pass laws that violate
natural rights
okay thank you
are there any further questions
thank you
up next is john dejoy to speak in
opposition to the bill
thank you madam chair members of the
committee for the record my name is john
dejoy i'm here representing the new
hampshire chapter of the national
association of social workers
the nesw is a national we are a state
branch of that
representing social workers across the
state of new hampshire we currently have
nearly 700 members
who provide mental health as well as
medical case management
interventions
we rise in opposition to this bill
if i could just step back off my remarks
for a second it has been
i felt sad
hearing the testimony
of all the folks that have come before
me and
the
the intent that they have to protect
their kids
that doesn't make this a better bill it
does make it an issue that is a really
important issue
parents rights are essential as you've
heard
parents rights though are already well
enumerated
in the constitution
in statute
and in new hampshire case law
this bill upends long stand the
long-standing new hampshire principle
of local controls
of schools
rather than legislative control of local
schools
this seeks to create a one-size-fits-all
state level intervention
that ought to be addressed through
school board elections which happen
every other year
finally the nasw opposes hp 1431
for one essential reason beyond that
children
we've heard a lot today about states
rights about parents rights about state
what the state should do
we have not heard about children's
rights and this committee has struggled
with the issue of children's rights over
the last number of sessions
children as new hampshire and u.s
citizens
enjoy their own constitutional rights
separate and distinct from their parents
but those rights have been diminished
through case law
hb 1431
proposes to further diminish
those rights
so that parents can have
what they see as increased rights
i mentioned that many social workers are
mental health counselors and therapists
working in a number of areas working
with kids working with adults
many of us here are also parents
i happen to be a grandfather for the
first time
we all know
that it is
optimal it is best practice that
children should always talk to their
parents
but we also know that every family
structure does not function in the same
way and every child is not comfortable
at all times talking to their parents
legislating that kids have to talk to
their parents
will not be any more successful
than today
only by talking to our children
and
talking to the school administrators the
teachers the school boards
can we truly come to an understanding of
this
legislating will just get put another
law in the books that won't
provide any more effect
than the current laws on the books do
for that reason the nesw employs this
committee
to itl this bill
in the future we are more than happy to
work with any groups who want to try to
address this through other means we'd be
happy to be involved in that
and with that i'll conclude my remarks
thank you are there any questions
representative belanger
thank you madam chair thank you mr dejoy
for being here today and testifying on
behalf of this bill
what i failed to
mention earlier when i was asking my
questions was the case law and you had
just insinuated that there is case law
in new hampshire
that
give parents rights can you
reference that case lies off the top of
my head i don't know what it is
thank you for the question
representative and i i wish i'm always
proud of my memory so i wish i could
cite the case law
i will i'm aware that
chief justice brock wrote the opinion
i'm not off standing here i can't give
you the case though i can probably pull
it up fairly easily
but the essence of the law
recognized the parents constitutional
rights
and did not recognize
constitutional rights of the children
follow up madam chai follow up thank you
thank you for answering my question mr
dejoy
um in regards to this bill
do you think that that case law
in in your professional opinion is
sufficient that this bill isn't needed
let me let me begin by saying that i am
not a lawyer nor do i pretend to be a
lawyer
i i can only the way i can answer that
representative
is to talk about an issue that i was
involved with this committee in
four five six years ago
when we were trying to change the child
protection statutes
to further protect children because
there was a disclaimer in the statutes
and every time we we made a move
the lawyers at the table
would say something effective you can't
do that it violate would violate the
case law
and so we were left with
not many options to try to protect
protect children
i think that between the case law the
constitution and the statutes as they
stand today
these laws are well enumerated to
provide
parents
significant protections
no further questions madam chair thank
you
representative ocala
thank you thank you for taking the
question in the example that we heard
previously
about nashua um
in
and in your testimony you say that there
is enough already um
case law and laws
protecting parents rights
would you suggest that
that in the case of dealing with schools
um that there
um could be an improvement or you think
that that also is um
satisfactory at this current time thank
you
thank you for the question
representative and i i
i'll
[Music]
i'll not comment on any of the specific
anecdotes because i don't have both
sides of the story
it may be entirely as it was presented
it may not be or maybe somewhere in the
middle so commenting on that is would be
inappropriate but i will say that in any
human interactions
things can always be better
you know how many husbands and wives
have misunderstood each other
you know we can always communicate
better
i
i don't know what's happened in nashua
or any other school district except mine
here in concord
but
it's it strains my belief
that
that no that a school board would refuse
to talk
constructively about
issues that's why i reference the
elections
you know you all represent your
constituents i'm sure you all have done
things that anger your constituents
they have the ability every two years to
reelect you and not reelect you
and that's the same with the school
board
follow-up
oh no
i was
are there any further questions
okay seeing none thank you very much
all right so the time is 12 35 we're
gonna go um and break until 1 45 for
lunch
so we will be in recess until
1 45.
this
um
there's
uh
um
so much
because
okay
uh
is
oh
foreign
yes
teachers
foreign
um
you
i will
you know
all right
yes
oh
is
i don't know how to do that kind of
thing
oh
now
okay
down
five
uh
yes
oh
nice
all that stuff
something
else
okay i'm going to call the
hearing for h.b 14 31
back in order
up next will be representative mark
allegro
just and speak in support of the bill
for 10 minutes
thank you
and good afternoon
committee members and madam chair
i'm going to modify my testimony a
little bit starting with
i thought i was going to be saying good
morning to you
but that's not the case
so
i'll get right to the point i'm going to
modify
by
changing a couple things that address
some of the earlier
comments in the day let me
give my
name again my credentials my name is
mark allegro i'm the representative from
grafton's district 7.
my background i am a scientist and an
educator and after a 35-40 year career i
can tell you i've
taught thousands of licensed physicians
medical students graduates all the way
down to grade three
so i'm going to focus on education
and i can tell you that i don't speak
with a total absence of knowledge
now
i'm going to start off by saying a funny
thing happened to me on the way to this
uh committee hearing
my daughter who's now 30 years old told
me within the past 48 hours she was
actually speaking to my wife
she said something that we sort of knew
but that she actually came clean with
she told my wife
mom you know i never talked to you about
this before
but i'm going to tell you what they told
us when i was a kid in school
they actually worked proactively on
separating us from you i have two
daughters they actually
essentially told us
teacher friend
parent enemy
now there are some people who made
comments in here earlier that they found
it difficult to believe some of these
things that are being testified too i'm
here to provide you with some case
studies some documents
okay
i'm here to tell you first that there's
no amount of lipstick that will prettify
this pig
all right this is the term horrified was
used and it is horrifying i don't
horrify easily but i'm telling you that
this is a serious problem
the problem is
is that we send our kids off to school
and we expect them to learn mathematics
geography
history
spelling reading and writing and instead
they're subjected to political
indoctrination
and there's a couple of topics in
particular
i'm not choosing these because i like
them best i'm telling you because in my
research they're the ones that show up
the most
kids are taught things
like
all white children from the moment of
birth
are racists
every white person is a racist and
always will be and only white people can
be racist
okay
they're taught things and i can tell you
from my own research experience
uh somebody who has studied the cell
molecular biology of development and
reproductive biology
they're also taught
the false narrative that
with the drug regime and some plastic
surgery
a boy can be turned into a girl and a
girl can be turned into a boy
well there are a lot of parents
who find these falsehoods not only
objectionable but repugnant
let's not forget
these kids
are
yours
despite what anybody might say
these kids
belong to the parents
they are legally
morally emotionally
in charge
and responsible
despite what anyone might think between
the hours of nine o'clock and three
o'clock in the afternoon
school officials across the country
don't like the pushback that they're
getting on this
so they've resorted to
concealment
deception
and even deceit
i'm going to lay out a few examples of
these things
right these deal with resignations
convictions indictments
lawsuits this isn't just stuff i'm
reading on high wire press
all right
and lest
lest we make any fake excuse that this
is this stuff that's happening in the
other 49 states
is it happening in new hampshire no
not new hampshire
well i'm here to tell you yes and i'm
going to finish up my testimony with
just a couple of examples in new
hampshire listen
i'm a house member i sit through
committee i know how to pick apart bills
too and one of the first questions is
always
well is this really a problem in new
hampshire
yes
most decidedly it is a problem in new
hampshire and it's within our power to
do something about it
so let me just give you a few examples
from across the nation
in missouri's rockwood school district
a school district official
instructed teachers and principals
you get a load of this in case you have
any doubt about this from anything that
was said before instructed
school teachers and principals
to make up one curriculum
that you give to the parents
and one that's the one we're really
going to teach
i'm not pulling your leg
i'm not pulling your leg i see knitted
brows your brows should be knitted you
should have big frowns on your faces
concealment
in florida's deer lake middle school
school officials saw fit
to guide a 13 year old girl
through
a i hesitate to use the word transition
without her parents knowledge
you've also heard other recent cases
about this that involve suicide attempts
by a young girl
this is a different one
there's bunches of these in florida and
california
around the country
in virginia's prince william county
and i have a quote here
a quote that comes
from subpoenaed documents
that contradict
what the school was presenting to the
public
virginia prince william county school
board chair told a parent that they're
not teaching
the tenets of critical race theory
but then in a private communication to
another school board official
he says and this is a truncated version
well i've always maintained crt is what
we're doing here
i don't believe in transparency or
public discussion did you hear that
public discussion
this is disturbed
it's disturbing and it's disturbed
well
let's head into new hampshire less than
anybody think this is just happening in
the other 49 states okay
right here in new hampshire
hanover case in sau 70.
they have a class
this is for staff
no i'm sorry this is for students i'm
confusing it with another one
the title of the curriculum is
exploring whiteness
it goes on from there i don't remember
the rest of it exploring whiteness
could you imagine
if you substitute almost any other word
in there for whiteness
well a parent was curious about this
course
so they inquired they were told no
we're not teaching the tenets of
critical race theory here well of course
the parent found out that that wasn't
the case that they are
that parent was then harassed
spoken over shut out of meetings and
later found out
that contrary to statute the school
board was conducting meetings privately
and not publicly
hanover new hampshire
in newmarket
the process of hiring a school
superintendent is supposed to be a
public
matter meetings is supposed to be held
in public screening
for evaluations
so on and so forth
well there's actually somebody that's
under a criminal complaint perjury
charges and has resigned in the new
market school system i don't remember
it's the assistant uh school board
chairman or the school board chairman
it's not important right now
okay
they lied
they said that
they denied first that there were any
private meetings
they uh
insisted
that
the minutes of the meeting after they
had to admit that there were meetings
were sealed they were not sealed until
finally
one of uh her colleagues
for lack of a better term i'll use the
vernacular ratted her out
and now she's facing perjury charges
let me tell you about thornton new
hampshire
thornton's a town just north of me
people attended a school board meeting
they asked
the school board members could you place
curriculum material materials in the
library
they were told no one school board
member actually questioned publicly why
should we have to have input from
parents
well maybe because some of us are
educated and have expertise that even
you lofty individuals don't have that's
number one but i have a couple of better
reasons how about because like i was
when i was teaching i'm a servant of the
public how about because you're a
servant of the public and we taxpayers
we pay your salary and we pay for the
curriculum development and we pay for
the curriculum materials and we pay for
these brick walls
that you work within each and every day
how about that as a good reason
here's the ironic aspect of my theory of
my testimony and um then i'm just going
to make a closing statement and
be
particularly delighted to answer any
questions you see answering questions is
what i did for 40 years at the lab bench
in the classroom
so i'll be very happy to answer even
some of the questions that were
addressed to other speakers before
these cases that i mentioned to you from
around the country and here in new
hampshire
they're just a few examples of many
all right
but the irony is is that
a couple of months ago
i contacted
our school principal
and i explained
in an email
you know this is a problem parents have
lost confidence in the school system
i understand that some of this this
stuff isn't going on in the campton
schools but
it would be really a good idea i think
for a few of us to get together
and get ahead of this before it becomes
a problem in our school district we
don't want parents being labeled
terrorists we don't want lawsuits and
resignations let's get together and see
what we can do to head off a potential
problem
that was in december
and i've heard nothing
so
apparently this lofty individual has
deigned
to not even
reply to my communication
we have a problem here houston
all right when a state rep contacts you
politely i know i could be sharp edged
sometimes but i sent him a polite email
offering to get together and see what we
could do to help everybody involved
and doesn't even receive a reply like
thank you
mr allegro but
i'm not i'm too busy right now can we
set this for some time in the future
look hb 1431 is sorely needed
in spite of the disturbed insistence
that when we drop our kids off on the
sidewalk at the school that they're no
longer our kids for those eight or so
hours
in spite of the disturbed insistence
that parents use schools
as babysitters that's not the case kids
belong to
their parents
i don't care if there are people who
don't believe that or not it's a fact
it's a natural fact and it's a natural
right
the same parents who pay for the school
buildings the salaries the curricula the
development and the materials of those
curricula
they rightfully demand
and more importantly they deserve
transparency
that's what hb
provides
and i'll be happy to take any questions
i ask you
please
don't worry about house etiquette and
don't worry about being delicate in the
structure of your questions
you won't hurt my feelings and i'll
answer them as best i can with a yes or
no whenever possible thank you for your
attention
are there any questions
representative pertegnet
my mouth isn't working thank you madam
chair thank you representative for
taking my question
you uh made reference to curriculum uh a
number of times and i think in one
instance you had talked about two sets
in a particular school district may i
ask i have a bad ear and i'm going to
ask you to
how's that is that a little better
go ahead okay so
you had referenced curriculum a number
of times and i think in one example you
said the school district had two
different sets depending upon the
circumstance
my understanding of curriculum
development and i too am a teacher of 40
years and i've chaired curriculum
committees
it's a process that takes a few years
and
it involves parents and stakeholders in
the community
and when the document is created after a
number of years
it has to be approved by the school
board
and as a result being approved by the
school board with so many stakeholders
wouldn't you say that it reflects
local community standards so maybe the
use of the word curriculum is different
from instructional practices i just want
some clarification on that
sure so i i want to make sure i heard
the beginning of of what you're asking
me uh did you mention that i said that
sometimes there's two curricula is did i
hear that right if if i understood you
correctly i believe you
gave an example where you said there
were two different sets of curriculums
depending upon the circumstance one for
one group one for another and i said
that's that can't be because a
curriculum is a document that has
developed over a number of years and you
can view it on the school district's
website and it's approved by the school
board so maybe the use of the word
curriculum is different from maybe
instructional practice or no i'm using
the word curriculum as it's intended to
be used this isn't a case where there
was an evolving curriculum or two
separate curricula for the same use
i think i was clear in stating that
the principals and the teachers were
instructed
to present one curriculum to parents
but teach another okay
that's unacceptable now um let me see
the rest of your question if i can
answer it uh if i can recall it you were
asking about it being an evolving thing
would repeat it please i'm sorry
no my question specifically was on the
two different sets of curriculum and i
think you've answered that question um
if i made madame yeah i remember
that follow-up um the curriculum is a
matter of public document
and so very often it can be found on the
school's website right so if there is an
official curriculum that parents can see
yes how then is it possible for the
school district to turn around and tell
the parents something totally different
thank you which is very evident when
they just look online thank you for that
question you made my point precisely you
see
that's the way it should be and if
that's the way it was we wouldn't have
any problem i myself have attempted to
retrieve curricula from schools and so
has my wife and acquaintances in fact
most recently
in campton a school board member has
requested the curriculum and was denied
if it works the way that you and i are
used to working
yeah it's posted on online
and it's what's being actually taught to
the kids
but most often i should say most often i
can't even if who cares if it's a
majority of times or not
too often
it's not available and a specific
request for that curriculum is met with
denial like you heard from some of the
parents in here now maybe they didn't go
about asking the right way i can't
you know testify to that
but if a parent comes into my office
and says to me may i have the you know
the curriculum for the uh american
history class or geography i'm saying
yeah okay and it's going to take me a
couple of days let me get it to you
that's not a problem
so i regret to say that
i'm not trying to be facetious but you
made my point exactly
the curricula too often is not
available to parents
thank you for that question
representative long
thank you madam chair
thank you representative i go back to
your recent conversation with your 30
year old daughter saying that the school
was trying to pull her
from you did she indicate whether that
was successful or close to being
successful or
so the last thing he said was what
whether that was what were supposed to
be what
that
i'm wondering if if your daughter
indicated whether that was successful or
close to being successful well that
affected her not entirely
i can't tell you well first of all with
all due respect what difference does
that really make if that's what was
being done
maybe with my daughter
who had parents that were willing to
fight to fight a little harder than
others maybe it wasn't successful
but i'm going to tell you without
getting
too much into my personal story
i suspect it caused a great deal of
difficulty in our family a great deal of
difficulty
okay but we fought the fight and
our daughter's with us
and for her to come back
15 18 years later
you know we suspected this kind of thing
i mean we knew it but only in general
not the kind of thing you could testify
about but we knew it my wife was a
couple of years ahead of me on this
okay but when my daughter 15 to 18 years
later comes back and tells me mom dad
this was a specific
effort there were specific proactive
practices
to pull me away from you
and if you think that i'm making up some
wackadoodle story you need to talk to
more parents this goes on all the time
the parents
are not the friend
the teacher's the friend
i hope that addressed your question
uh sure
thank you
representative yokela
thank you thank you for taking the
question
um
do you believe that the
taxpayers that paid for the
curriculum to be produced that it's
really their
curriculum and that they should have
access to it and it's not a special
right to just parents but actually it's
a right of all the taxpayers well yeah
quite honestly if you've paid for
something you have a right to it
um you know whether you have an interest
in seeing her you know when you're
my age and if you don't have any
children maybe it's not that important
to you
but
uh
you know for instance as an educator not
even
currently active
if i wanted to go into
[Music]
you know a
nashua public school
and say hey may i see the curriculum
because i'm developing a program of my
own and it would be really helpful for
me to see this
i can't predict the future but if you
would like to play that game with me
why don't we do that i'll go down there
and request it let's see what the reply
is
i'll give odds
so yes it should be a right to answer
your question directly it should be a
right yes and what would the reason be
for hiding it
none that i can think of
not if you're doing the right thing
you know when you've stolen cookies from
the cookie jar that's when you tuck them
in your pocket not when you've asked and
received honestly
are there any other questions
saying none thank you thank you
up next is ed groves
to speak in support of the bill for two
minutes
thank you committee members
uh my name is ed groves um i've been
coming up here
for the better part of a couple years
usually screaming outside in the front
of the state house with my flag
no mandates freedom
any other
live free or die
activity that we need to support
so eight weeks ago i decided to come to
a
hearing about house bill i can't
remember when it was but i looked at all
of them and said you know what maybe i
want to go up there and testify for
freedom no mandates
and i've
been on the freedom side of most of
these most of us here this morning were
and
are at just about every single meeting
other than hospital administrators and
paid lobbyists
i've come to one conclusion
on either side
that we
as adults have effectively been
torturing our children for two years
literally torturing my daughter is a
freshman at keene state college i'll be
really brief with this she spent a year
and a half
on her bed with a computer graduating
from manchester central high school
was she clinically depressed i don't
know i'm not a shrink
she was not herself for
the better part of a year she gets into
college goes to keene state has a great
first semester
3.37 yay
one week into second semester she gets a
visit from a student advocate um i know
her name's kathy that's all i know
goes through a whole bunch of stuff with
my daughter how was your first semester
yada yada she gets the end of it she
says so courtney um i understand you're
not vaccinated
my daughter's
no i'm not but
why is it your business well you might
as well get vaccinated because you're
going to need a vaccination to graduate
from keene state college in three and a
half years so my daughter calls me up
crying dad what do i do what do i do
what do i do i said well you don't get
vaccinated first of all and that's not a
fact yet and we hope it's not going to
be
the point is
our kids have been like i said tortured
for the better part of two years and
the only common denominator is covin we
all know that masks and
isolation i just really need you to get
to the text of this bill
okay so
what this bill will do
is
take the government out of our kids
lives and give it back to the parents
the point is that the government has
really been torturing our kids like i'm
i don't want to make my kids wear masks
in schools but the schools and the
government are making me do it so
what we need to do is give this bill
there's nothing in there i
talked to a couple of you after and
there are tweaks that need to be done
but for anybody to sit here and say that
the school should have more rights over
our kids than the parents you're crazy
and if you don't think this is happening
in new hampshire my final point here
is this letter was written
to
the house education committee
please vote no on house bill 1015. we're
not talking about that bill but
reference it's basically a bill saying
that if you're teaching health or sex
education you're going to need to give
the curriculum ahead of time so the
parents can opt out if they'd like to
sounds common sense to me
the letter goes on to say your calling
is to the legislature
others are called to medicine
teachers are called to teach let us do
our jobs without interference from
parents and laws do your job and vote no
so we can do our job and teach
that was submitted
by the president of the teachers
association at timberlane high school
timberlane school district i'm not going
to say her name you can find that out
yourself but for somebody in charge to
have that much arrogance
and that much
me me me it's it's
disgusting and by the way if we want to
end all this covid i know i'm not
supposed to talk about this bill either
but if you fast track bill 1022 iver
mekton kovit goes away
are there any questions
thank you
up next is anne-marie banfield
to speak in support of the bill for
three minutes
good afternoon
my name is anne-marie banfield i'm a
parental rights advocate in new
hampshire who is primarily focused on
academic excellence and education today
come to urge you to vote ought to pass
on house bill 1431.
i've been working as a parental rights
advocate in new hampshire for about 15
years
i tend to be in front of the house
education committee so thank you for
hearing my testimony today they know me
pretty well over there
i think it's also important to mention
that in that time i have never received
a diamond compensation
my focus is on academic excellence in
education so much of the time has been
spent again
reporting before the house education
committee
parents who struggled
to be a voice for their children
oftentimes run into lobbying
organizations that are well-funded
and hire high-priced attorneys
to fight against them
the irony is that those organizations
and individuals are paid out of the
school budget through dues
in essence parents pay the salaries of
those attorneys and lobbyists who are
hired to fight against them
i would assume that some of them will
probably have opposed this bill or may
i want to make it clear again that i
have no financial stake in advocating
i've done this on behalf of parents and
i'm here today because it's the right
thing to do
school administrators have high priced
legal teams that can be extremely
intimidating to parents not to mention
they are there to protect the school
system the balance of power has been
against parents for many years
even if parents have a good case the
legal cost of them to fight a
superintendent who can use
taxpayer-funded attorneys results in
parents giving up they tend to just
leave the public schools you want why
enrollments dropping
that's why
public school enrollment declines
private schools and home school numbers
increase in the state check the data
a parental rights bill would help shift
some of that power back to the parents
i've seen parents lose court cases after
their children were assaulted
in school manchester student drug down
the stairs by her hair
lost a lawsuit
parents have been denied access to their
child's classroom to obser observe
i want to add that that is an extremely
rare
request by a parent most parents don't
want to go into a classroom and observe
number one you know sometimes it
embarrasses their kids
um but it does happen in the 15 years
i've had two
two parents i don't think you're going
to see this influx of parents into the
classroom i've had two parents contact
me
when i think we're going to hear from
today
in one of the cases many years ago i had
to turn to former state senator peter
bragdon who had also served on the
school board in his town
he managed to facilitate a father's
request to observe his child's classroom
i shouldn't have to reach out to a state
senator in order to pull some strings
just so a parent can observe their
child's classroom
these parents are good parents they want
to figure out what's going on
how can i help the teacher most of the
time it's because there's a problem that
needs to be addressed and maybe if they
saw their kid in action they would
actually be supporting the teacher i
don't know
public schools are public everything
should be made transparent unless there
is a reason to keep a student's personal
information private
from the curriculum to the materials to
the classroom nothing should be hidden
from parents but it is
enrollment continues to drop in new
hampshire schools there are various
reasons for this trend but i also
believe that if parents have some
fundamental rights to exercise they may
be more likely to keep their children in
the public schools if they leave they
take a portion of that money and the
school loses that money
um just that's the end of my testimony
but i just wanted to bring up some
points that i think
might help in some of this that's been
presented to you
what is in federal law
and what guides schools sometimes
will also have loopholes
so
you might say well if this law
as it's presented
already is in federal law well let me
tell you something school administrators
will
exploit any
loophole in those laws and i've seen it
i've seen it firsthand it's why we have
the non-academic survey law in law in
new hampshire
because the ppra federal law which is
supposed to require parental consent for
non-academic surveys that law was
exploited by administrators
administrators said we don't need
parental consent on these non-academic
surveys because in the federal law
it says if a student is required to take
a survey
then we need parental consent
we don't require the students this is
voluntary now when you put a survey in
front of a student
they think it's a test they take a test
they put your name on it they put their
unique people identifier number on it
there's nothing anonymous about those
surveys as we have found so there are
loopholes oftentimes in these federal
laws this would help close those
loopholes
state law does that
i have personally filed right to no
request in some of these schools sau 16
being one of them
you know when i get back i'll get back
some documents and then some of the
questions they won't answer
they won't answer
now i've filed right to know requested
merrimack where not only did they answer
the question sometimes they give me all
kinds of information it depends on where
you file that right to know request we
have had school board members have to
file a right to know request to get
information doris hoencey in nashua who
used to sit on their school board had to
file right to no request and again had
trouble getting information from the
district where she served donna green
had to take her school district
timberlane to the supreme court
to get information
so you can imagine how difficult it can
be for parents i can't even get the
information sometimes and then if you
have to go to court
well thousands and thousands of dollars
but you know what the superintendents i
am just about finished thank you for
your patience superintendents they have
taxpayer-funded attorneys so they can
rake up the bill
they can fight these parents and they
are
we have court cases going on right now
where superintendents will not provide
information because they have those
attorneys available i'm happy to take
any questions um i can tell you that the
gentleman who spoke before me when it
comes to crt was right on the money
i can go there if you would like to but
i'm just going to leave it up to you if
you have any questions
are there any questions
seeing none thank you
up next is laura ellazam
to speak in support of the bill for one
minute
hi good afternoon i'm laura elazam from
londonderry
i consider myself very fortunate that my
children attend a school that explicitly
affirms parents as the natural primary
educators and caretakers of their minor
children
this is both our right and our
responsibility
and you know the system works really
well
um
when parents are treated that way it
fosters trust and accountability and
cooperation between the administrators
and the and the teachers and the parents
and that's good for the students
and actually it's kind of been the
default situation all around until
fairly recently
but now my school's attitude has become
increasingly uncommon
more and more we see an erosion in
parental prerogative
in some districts in some schools
there's open hostility to parental
involvement
at every level
it is the national school board
association that labeled parents who
sought answers at school boards
domestic terrorists i mean
that's chilling and it was designed to
be chilling we don't want to hear from
people who disagree with our policies is
the attitude of some of these school
boards
so enough is enough
the stuff that used to go without saying
doesn't anymore and i feel that this
bill really addresses that
parents who have children at schools
other than my unique school
particularly taxpayer-funded schools
they deserve better
and they deserve to see their children
reaping the benefits of respectful
collaboration between families and
schools
everyone benefits
so please tweak this bill if necessary
but pass a comprehensive parental bill
of rights for the benefit of our
students and of our school communities
thank you
are there any questions
seeing none thank you
up next is eric anthony
to speak in support of the bill for
three minutes
my name is eric anthony i'm from auburn
new hampshire and i thank you for the
opportunity can you just move a little
closer thank you for the opportunity to
address you on this important matter
and i'm doing so from the standpoint of
a case that i'm involved in in salem
district court
it's bossy versus
state versus bosse
and the primary
she was arrested
for not wearing a mask in a school
meeting
and this is after the school board had
put out a notice a week earlier that
said precisely that mass the attendees
were asked to wear a mask
a reasonable interpretation of that was
that masks were optional
especially this being
about three weeks after the governor's
order public order rescinding
the mask mandates
so
she went to the meeting she expected to
speak she actually got into the area
where
where people could be
seated
and she realized a friend of hers was
back in the hall area so she turned
around went back
and
she said i'm just going in you know he
was in in a conversation with the police
there
the police had by a second order by the
same school board
have been told to come they expected
some controversy and they were told to
block and arrest anybody without a mask
so uh she was
at that point a police officer turned
around grabbed her and arrested her so
is this a student no this is a parent
this is a grandparent specifically she
was there with her daughter son
and granddaughter and she planned to
speak at the meeting
and
so this
sets up a
conflict of law is it so
elemental so classic it goes back i
think before the magna carta
it's called it's called an ex post facto
law
where somebody where she was given the
expectation the printed expectation that
she could enter the meeting without
wearing a mask then she was arrested for
wearing a mask
but but so
this bill wouldn't change that
right this this bill is about wearing a
mask to a meeting that's totally
different this is about parental rights
over their children
but this is squarely in your
jurisdiction by section 4 and 4 c
for children for overseeing the children
though right this isn't about an adult
in a meeting
do you know what i'm saying
you you have you have granted these
school boards in effect starting i
haven't granted the school boards the
school board would refer back to the
statutes they'd refer up to the chain of
command
these school boards think that they've
been granted
in effect star chamber justice
to mete out the laws and they they are
the law and they say when
they are the law and
you have no no choice or
recourse
i understand but this bill does not
change the fact that the school board's
requiring
parents to wear masks to a meeting okay
this is about parents rights over their
children
it speaks to governmental authorities if
i get uh section 4 and 4c here
a parent of a minor child has
inalienable rights that now are more
comprehensive than those listed in
this section
and uh i'm gonna let you go on but i'm
going to tell you that that's not what
this bill does
okay
so you can you can continue but because
you're going to argue with me regardless
but i'm just making it clear to you that
this bill does not stop a school board
from acquiring meetings of masks at a
meeting
okay
right anne marie because i see you
shaking your head you know right
a parental bill of rights in any case
because this is a travesty this person's
civil rights parental rights have been
wholesale have been violated
and
so that's why i'm here to speak
thank you all right thank you
are there any questions
seeing none thank you very much
up next is
laurie orton ortolano
i probably just butchered that i'm sorry
lori ordolano
from nashua
okay
um
russ and
russ and chester
to speak in support of the bill
thank you committee chair thank you
committee members
um
i've been doing a lot of activity here
in both
representatives hall and over in the
legislative building uh since
i have realized that one of the problems
in our state is the fact that
we as citizens
taxpayers parents
have lost faith
we've lost faith in the transparency
and the integrity
of so many of our lives not just our
lives but our children's lives
one of the nice things that covet 19 did
because i like to look through
everything through heroes colored
glasses is it put parents back more
involved with their children's lives
isn't that's what our educators have
been crying about for so long the
teachers are not involved
um
i wanted to talk a little bit about
sorry i want to talk a little bit about
some of the things
that i believe and i know has been
happening for years i can tell you
stories about my fifth grade child who
was physically abused by a teacher
and it had been going on for months
she was a drama queen
i didn't believe her
to this day
i cannot forgive myself
for taking the side of that teacher over
the side of my child
and if i had not found that suicide note
in the trash can
i may never
have been able to see my grandchildren
or
be in at her wedding
because when i found that suicide note
i finally said
okay
what's going on and i tried to talk to
my child about it and she said
why should i talk to you
i've been
why should i talk to you you didn't
believe me i told you what she was what
this teacher was doing to other kids and
you didn't believe me and you didn't
want to do anything about it
so why should i talk to you now
i immediately marched to school and said
i want my child removed from this
classroom
what happened was they said no
we've already had to remove 16 children
from that classroom since the beginning
of the school year i was like
whoa
what
what are you talking about yes but it's
all the children the children are the
problem your child is socially
emotionally disturbed
and you need to do something about it
and you need to get in our counseling
and i said
so
this is the 17th child
i started doing a little investigation
on the teacher
she had been moved seven times in the
last two years through the school
district
because of complaints against her
at no point in time was the public ever
made aware of what was going on at no
point in time did the school principals
or the school district or anyone try to
help those the parents and the children
there are the reason why we're begging
for this parental rights bill is because
the school boards the school districts
the teachers the counselors all have big
money behind them they all have the
protection of the new hampshire
counselors association and the new
hampshire teachers association and
what did parents have
really what do parents have now
we have stripped away parental rights in
this state and in this country we have
also said you know what teachers you
know better than we do we're just going
to let you do your thing
what i know
is
child suicide is up
abuse and neglect of children in the
schools is up
test grades are down
school enrollment is down
school proportion of taxes is way up
why i feel very strongly
that it's because
parents are starting to
find teeth and find people to represent
them and litigate the kind of things
that i should have been able to do as a
single parent but i could not
this parental right bill gives parents
the resources to fight back against the
bad educators against the bad
administrations and against the bad
school boards and i will tell you it's
not it didn't just start happening
recently this happened over 25 years ago
in this state in this in this city
i can also tell you another story where
my other child
um
was the the school counselor took it
upon herself to make the decision that
she was a neglected and or emotionally
disturbed child or neglected or abused
child my stepdaughter was neglected and
or abused not by me
but by a previous guardian
the school teacher the the school
counselor and the school teacher took it
upon themselves to take that child under
their wings and say
this is safe this is a safe place you
don't have to worry about anything
that's going on at home
you can talk to us don't talk to your
parents because obviously they're the
problem
a report was made to dcs
who i worked for at the time i was a
child protective service worker for 17
years in this state
i was told because there was an
investigation i had to move out of my
home
or my child would be put into foster
care
i moved out of my home for six months
during that time
my child
my my
husband did not believe that anything
bad had ever happened to the child
so he took her off all his all her meds
he took her out of counseling
and my child ended up in the criminal
justice system in this state because she
attacked a teacher
and it was all because a counselor
thought it was a good idea to make a
report instead of having a conversation
that's one of the things that's happened
in our society there are no
conversations between teachers and
school boards and parents and and
students anymore
i can talk about my son
my son who said
yeah when i wanted to come out
i my teacher told me don't come out to
your parents now fortunately she liked
me but she didn't like the the
ex-husband
so and we had 50-50 custody
so
my son
makes the decision that my husband can't
be true my ex-husband can't be trusted
fortunately
we were
not
a one a true parent we were
cooperatively working together so when
he when my son came out to me
i was able to help him
coordinate conversations with his father
i had no idea at that time that the
teacher said don't tell
so the fact that you folks say uh it
doesn't really not you folks i'm sorry i
don't mean to identify any of you um but
the facts that we say oh it's outliers
oh it's just a few towns oh it's just a
few teachers it's just a few school
boards it's just a few no
it's not it's it's here in new hampshire
it's been going on for a long time and
it's time to say no more
um i have a number of um
testimonies facebook groups
facebook groups good bad or indifferent
it's a great place for keyboard warriors
to find out what's really going on
you don't have to look very far
bedford new hampshire
the school districts voted for there
were over 150 parents at the school
board meeting
that did not want certain
school books in the classroom
um
and they said
and the argument was we shouldn't ban
books
okay
the parents said okay let's talk about
this how about if instead of having a
book
that is inappropriate for a middle
school
student
available
from
age five all the way up
instead of that let's put some
restrictions on it within the school
library or within the classroom
so that parents are aware
the school board the school board said
yeah that sounds like a great the school
district said yeah that sounds like a
great idea they went behind the parents
back and voted four to zero to allow
that book in with no no stipulation
whatsoever that's a reality we can't
trust our school boards we can't trust
our school districts and unfortunately
we can't trust our educators
we can't trust any aspect of our
children's lives anymore do i think it's
on purpose do i think it's by accident
do i think it's just that there's some
nefarious people in every aspect of our
children's and our lives
the bottom line is
this piece of legislation would allow
parents to try and weed out those
nefarious characters and it would
further support
conversations
it would further support
parents being held accountable and
responsible as much as educators should
be held accountable responsible as much
as school board members budget committee
members i have tried for over a year and
a half
to underst to act to request certain
things we're not allowed in the school
library
if you're a parent you're not allowed in
the school library you can't even come
into the school classroom
in my school district
and the argument is well parents don't
really have time or energy for that
anyways
so
educators can't have it both ways
they can't have it both ways if they
don't want to be the babysitters then
they need to start working
collaboratively cooperatively and for
the whole child not just the student and
the parents need to be held accountable
and responsible too
and there is a mechanism
there is a mechanism already in place
if parents are not being
appropriate there's a mechanism everyone
in this state
is a mandated reporter so there's
already a mechanism in place so this
bill
does not prevent
children's rights
at all
if anything i would say it helps it
helps improve
children's rights parents rights
teachers rights
school administration rights
and taxpayers rights
thank you thank you are there any
questions
representative ocala
thank you thank you for the question for
taking the question
um
when there is an issue with a teacher
and it is being addressed by the school
board
or
the administration all of those records
are
are kept from the public and
kept from the parents
so
my question to you is
do you believe that
in the example that you gave when there
was
an obvious
issue going on in that classroom
um
should the parents have been notified
and which mechanism and
would allow them to be notified so that
they could
do this or do you have a suggestion for
for solving that problem thank you very
much
i to this day
do not know
exactly what went on in that classroom
and what went on in the the other
assignments before getting there i do
know that a comment was made to me
after the teacher was brought up on
criminal charges because i witnessed the
teacher i started going to that
classroom every day
when my daughter was not allowed to move
to a different classroom i went to that
classroom every day
i didn't see anything i was convinced my
daughter was a drama queen
one day my daughter was sick and i was
so excited i didn't have to go to fifth
grade today
she came to me crying she's like you've
gotta be there you have no idea what
she's gonna do to those kids if you're
not there
i went there
i heard a commotion down at the end of
the hallway and i noticed for the first
time all the other classrooms were
closed all their doors were closed and
as i got closer and closer to that
classroom i witnessed that teacher
physically slamming the locker the
locker thing
the locker door
on this child's arm
there was a criminal complaint she was
found guilty but that was after two
years
after two years of being shoved around
and that principle's comment so i didn't
try to intervene i immediately walked
down and and and this was before cell
phones even so i immediately
well may not have been before cell
phones but um i immediately walked down
to the walk down to the principal the to
the guidance counselor's office and said
call 9-1-1 it's an emergency call 9-1-1
didn't say anything else went into the
principal's office
and he said
they assured me that they assured me
that the fifth graders would be safe
with her
that was a direct quote
and that was brought up too and that
principal and that school board and that
school district was never held
accountable and responsible
what more can i say
are you all set representative yokela
yes thank you
there any further questions
all right seeing none thank you thank
you
up next is danielle
honan
is that right
to speak in support of the bill for
three minutes
thank you for allowing me to come here
and speak and be a voice for my children
i recently moved here from massachusetts
to a nice we wanted a smaller community
better schools and i have been fighting
with the schools ever since we moved
here i've been trying to advocate for my
children non-stop and i've got nothing
but pushback i've been very nice and
respectful and i am done i cannot wait
to pull my kids out of new market i'm
ashamed i'm embarrassed i came here
to better my children we came here as a
couple to better our kids and it has
been a nightmare my son is in
kindergarten my daughter is in second
grade
my son's been experiencing bullying
and
the superintendent has done nothing the
teacher did nothing it has been insane
and i have tried to observe the
classroom i wanted to go into the
library i can't go into the school i
can't even get a response from the
superintendent the school board anybody
i email the teachers the superintendent
the only person who is responding to me
is the commissioner of education like
that is insane to me i have been
completely muted and it is
disgraceful
it is so upsetting to me and i am doing
whatever i can to be able to afford
private school i already did tours i can
go into the classroom i'm having
conversations it's not right
i feel like this bill would give parents
the opportunity to be able to be a voice
for their children
my kindergartener has anxiety he's
counting down the days until he is out
of school
he has developed anxiety he is sick he
says he's sick every monday monday
tuesday wednesday thursday friday he
gets excited because he has gym he has
pe
so that's when he's excited to go to
school and every day he wanted to come
here with me today and he's like but he
gets nervous he's developing anxiety he
is the most amazing kid and
it's so sad we've seen a complete change
my husband is getting more involved he's
understanding this which is awesome
we've come together as a family because
of this but it is so sad that we have to
create a bill of rights for parents to
get up here and speak
i have chicken scratches everywhere i i
want to be the advocate for my children
i want to represent their voice
and i will
do whatever it takes to be that voice
for them
i want to give them the rights that they
deserve through my guidance through my
education in the best way that i know
how the government does not know how to
parent my children i don't trust them i
don't trust the schools and
unfortunately we need to rise up and
protect these parents and in turn
protect the children
so i guess in closing
i really hope that this bill will keep
the honest people honest it will help
give
a reminder to the people that there are
rules and laws about about what is
natural and right
it will keep families informed
and involved and there should be nothing
to hide we also in newmarket cannot get
our curriculum
what is up with that
there's been multiple parents i'm
speaking for all
multiple parents here who have tried
non-stop to get these curriculums why
why are they being hidden from parents
why am i going to pay taxes in new
market and now pay a private tuition
i would so much rather do that than
expose my children
to this type of environment it's it's
it's so sad to me and we moved here
to completely for that reason and now
it doesn't even matter we're going to
we're going to private school because
i'm getting absolutely no response from
anybody
the teacher is completely
putting
my son up against us it is so awful he's
so afraid he bonked his head with it on
the playground equipment was bleeding
everywhere and he was afraid to even
tell anybody
that is awful he's afraid i i don't want
him to be afraid of other adults he's
afraid because i'm writing all these
medical
i i don't want my kids getting vaccines
in school i don't want them getting
medication we take really good care of
our health
we advocate for food
nutritious
everything with supplements we take
really good good care of ourselves and
he's afraid and i don't want to put him
in that position where he can't feel
like he can go ask for help when he's
literally bleeding all over the
playground
and he hates masks
i want to be able i can't even get a
medical exemption i have medical
exemptions for both of my children they
will not honor them in new market
and now my son has anxiety he's
developing anxiety how long is that
going to last coped lasted like a day in
our house
and now he's going to have
anxiety that i'm going to have to
try to manage
moving forward so
i'm happy to take any questions
thank you
thank you are there any questions
representative yokela
thank you and thank you for taking the
question um
if you had the ability to see the
curriculum and
go into the classroom if there was an
issue
would you
feel that you did not need to leave that
um public school
because there was something that you
that you had um
uh control over and so that you could
observe that
your child is is doing well in that
school
i yeah i think the biggest issue right
now is there's no transparency i don't
trust
anybody
they have given me no reason to trust
them if there was something that i
didn't agree with i would opt out i'm
currently opting out of a lot of things
already if they're showing videos on how
to wear a mask properly they're showing
videos on covid i just don't think that
is part of that should be part of the
curriculum
why why are they talking about that so
and they're still allowing it i have
specified very clearly of what my kids
are to opt out of if they decide to
share the information
copiod talks vaccinations all that stuff
being one of them and they're still
doing it
under my consent and they were just like
oh it's just a little i'm like no i
specifically said this and so my right
it's like they don't care
so if this were to be implemented and
going a lot and that was to be followed
i would absolutely i'd be like yep no my
kid can either
step out during that time
not be a part of it i just think there
needs to be transparency there needs to
be some understanding i don't want
secret i don't want a barrier put
between my kid and the school i want i
want them to be able to trust adults
trust educators
so yeah i think that would be
a totally different thing if there was
transparency like that among parents
there would be so much more trust
so much more
trust
thank you
are there any other questions
all right seeing none thank you very
much thank you
up next is
jama wilder
to speak in support of the bill for four
minutes
my name is jama wilder and i live in
hollis new hampshire thank you for your
time and desire to protect our rights
and our children
i was born and raised in new hampshire
and spent most of my 41 years living in
our beautiful state
my husband and i have five children
ranging from three to 17 years old
we enrolled our older children in hollis
brookline high school
starting in august i requested a
complete list of curriculum
including textbooks movies and reading
assignments
i was denied multiple times and told
that i could log into my children's
google classroom to see what resources
the teachers were using
on several occasions my children came
home with questionable material reeled a
riddled with inappropriate sexual
content divisive concepts
and reading books with a lexicon level
of a fourth or fifth grader
in some cases they were only allowed to
go to one resource
assigned by the teacher to do their
research
our res the resources used were very
biased
this practice is something the growth of
our children to be critical thinkers
when my daughter attempted to add a
direct quote to an assignment and give
her interpretation of the quote she was
told that her project seemed
argumentative
and that she needed to redo the
incitement
through the last several months
i would look on their google classrooms
and could not find the resources
my children told me about
there was absolutely no transparency
i wanted to be able to have a clear
picture of what was going on in the
schools so i completed the six hours
of volunteer training
when i completed all of my requirements
training background check and
fingerprinting to my surprise i was
denied the opportunity to volunteer
through the school
the principal told me that the school
doesn't offer them even though they were
short pairs and teachers at the time
i would need to find opportunities
through the parent student teacher
association i then requested to observe
a class citing essa 1116c
parental engagement
i was denied by the superintendent and
the principal
they said it was denied based on the
collective bargaining agreements and
student privacy
in our district i could put in an
application to substitute teach without
a teaching degree
and be running my own class
after questioning the things i was
seeing the administration informed me
that i was not allowed to meet with a
teacher or question them about any
curriculum and all questions should go
to the administration
it became very clear to me they didn't
want me anywhere near the school
the hyper focus on sexuality divisive
concepts and the constant focus on their
social and emotional learning is
planting seeds in these developing minds
it is destructive for our children and
as a parent
i should have had the opportunity to
voice my her my concerns and have been
heard
after working tirelessly for six months
i came to the conclusion i had no other
option than to remove my children from
the public school education until things
changed
i have seen a complete shift in our
educational system in the last couple of
decades
and as a parent it's frightening
this bill is so crucial to me because it
defines the parental rights in our
children's education
it appears to me that some
administration have forgotten that the
children belong to the parents and not
to the public education system
the job of parents is to direct the
upbringing of our children in their
moral and religious training
education health care mental health and
unconditionally love them
i would ask that you that in section 169
i three you strike the line in the
section that states without
demonstrating that such action is
reasonable and necessary to achieve a
compelling state interest and that the
such action is narrowly tailored and is
not otherwise served by a less
restrictive means
every parent has been blessed by god
with our precious babies and we know
what's best for them they belong to the
parents not to the state or the
government please opt to pass 1431 and
give rights back to the parents so we
can protect them and raise them in the
ways they should go
thank you
are there any questions
okay this is the last pink card so this
will be it for the day
a
brandono
oh al brandano
uh to speak in support of the bill for
two minutes
thank you everybody it's it's quite late
but you know i look around the room and
i'm amazed by
the wisdom not just on the walls but
with all of you all of you
this is a very difficult decision for
everybody
but there's some this one uniting thing
and everything you've heard today and it
doesn't matter what side of the aisle
you are from
it's about trust it really is
and trust is like it's a soap bubble
right once we lose it it's so hard to
get it back
and that's really the problem here
from one come many right eat glorious
uno right here in this room we're all
together
we're all parents we all have children
our grandchildren we know what that love
is all about
why would you not trust us
over school unions over a teachers
association i'm not saying they don't
have their place of course they do but
this bill is essential for us
i ask you please to vote in favor of
this bill thank you thank you are there
any questions
all right seeing none
that's a wrap for hb 1431
in closing the public hearing we'll take
a 10 minute break and be back for exact
session
are you talking to me
your mind
um
pictures
that's that's fantastic
is
babies are cute until they grow up
so again
is
um
do you know one of the five high schools
is
so
exactly that's why
because in my town
investigation right now
i wanted to run
one time a year
is
i
don't tell them
is
because that's because that's because he
doesn't represent
social medias
the easiest
um
is that every um
they schedule something like this that
has to do with students
they also
schedule
a conflictual bill with either
healthcare services or department of
education
now as a
to the point
is
let's work is and do something in
reality
and you know why because i don't trust
my representatives
so i have been here every day in the
morning until five at night sometimes
eight o'clock at night because i don't
trust my life
and and i know i know
so thank you very much for your time
that was in 205.
yes
so
today
says
all right so
1436. i'm going to open the exec session
on 1436
uh representative belanger
oh wait no 1436 representative nelson
do you have a motion
representative nelson see your list
i'm sorry can i just have one more
minute
apologize okay
yes
i apologize thank you madam chair roman
yes i
can hold on one moment i'm sorry
i make a motion to itl
okay
okay the motion is itl on
1436 is there any discussion
yes madam chair i have a couple of
things
okay okay
this bill could result in disputes
regarding the content of the record as
contents could be modified in different
recordings and subsequent transcripts
can differ from one another the subject
matter may not be confidential and could
easily be shared to different outlets
such as social media that could result
in devastating effects
okay
is there any further discussion
all right seeing none i'll have the
clerk call the roll the motion on the
floor is itl on house bill 1436.
representative desimone
yes
representative yokela
um
for the people watching in
if the people don't have mics then they
wouldn't be able to hear i'm just
trying to bring that to the chair's
attention but i'm also just voting yes
okay
yeah
i mean just be really loud because it's
just it's just awkward having
everybody on each side not being able to
see people
okay
great thank you
okay so representative yokela
on the vote
okay representative yokela votes yay
representative nelson
when you're done with it yes
representative nelson votes yes
representative belanger
representative cross
representative litchfield yes
representative litchfield votes yes
representative smith
representative smith votes yes
representative long yes representative
long votes yes representative alessia
representative alessa of ocs
representative grossman
representative grossman votes yes
representative levesque
representative levesque votes yes
representative wazir
representative wazir votes yes
representative petrino that's me the
clerk i vote yes
representative altschuler yes
representative altila votes yes
madam chair rice yes
representative rice votes yes without
objection this can go on the consent
calendar
it is
if it's an itl it can go on right
yeah but it was an otp
maybe
let's put it on the regular calendar
because i do remember that let's just be
safe because i don't remember
yeah
[Music]
yes
okay
yeah we're on a roll
all right the next
bill hb 1142
why isn't that on my sheet here
11.42 okay
that's going to be jody representative
nelson do you have a motion
yes madam chairman i'd like to make a
motion to itl
okay
seconded by representative belanger
is there any
discussion all right seeing none the
clerk can call the roll
i don't have it in front of me
do you have it in front of you
i don't know where my i was so organized
okay thank you
okay
sorry representative desimone
yes representative desimone votes yes
representative yokela
i vote yes representative yokola votes
yes representative nelson
yes representative nelson votes yes
representative belanger
representative bolanger votes yes
representative litchfield
representative litchfield votes yes
representative smith
representative smith votes yes
representative long yes representative
long votes yes representative alessia
representative alessia votes yes
representative grossman
representative grossman votes yes
representative levesque
representative levesque votes yes
representative wazir
representative wazir votes yes
i peter petrino the clerk votes yes
representative alzheler
yes representative also votes yes madam
chair right yes and she votes rice
and the motion is 14 to zero
any objection to consent
saying none i can go on consent
okay
all right
i think that's what's next
right okay
um up next we'll do
relative to the right of a party in a
family court case to create their own
written transcripts of court proceedings
are you ready representative patrick no
i'm sorry
okay
representative belanger do you have a
motion
second
seconded by representative desimone is
there any discussion
seeing none the clerk will call the role
representative desimone
yes representative desimona votes yes
representative yokela
yes thank you representative yes joe
keller votes yes
representative nelson yes representative
nelson votes yes representative belanger
representative belanger votes yes
representative litchfield
yes representative litchfield votes yes
representative smith
representative smith votes yes
representative long
representative long votes yes
representative alessia
representative alessia votes yes
representative grossman
representative grossman votes yes
representative levac
representative levesque votes yes
representative was here
representative waziri votes yes
representative petrino the clerk that's
me votes yes representative altsula
yes representative altila votes yes
representative chairman woman
madam rice
yes
without objection we can move consent
to zero
consent
oh we okay
all right so fifteen fifty is next
okay
uh hb 1550 relative to the right of
children and teenagers to testify in
family court proceedings representative
desimone do you have a motion i do madam
chair i
move itl please
seconded by representative belanger is
there any discussion
seeing none i'll have the clerk call the
roll when he's ready
thank you
representative
yes representative desimone votes yes
representative yokela
yes representative yokola votes yes
representative nelson
yes representative nelson votes yes
representative belanger
representative belanger votes yes
representative litchfield
yes representative litchfield votes yes
representative smith
representative smith votes yes
representative long yes representative
long votes yes representative alessia
representative alessia votes yes
representative grossman
representative grossman votes yes
representative levesque
representative votes yes representative
wazir
representative wazir votes yes
representative petrino that's me the
clerk i vote yes
representative altsula yes
representative
votes yes
madam chair rice
yes representative rice votes yes the
vote is 14-0
any objection to consent
it's an fn don't put it on consent
i'll have to get it clarified i mean if
i get it clarified do we want these on
consent
all right i'll i'll find that out
okay
um give me one second and i'll call call
the clerk real quick
please thank you
no the white one
give that to jody please thank you
jody has two
one for cody come get your
representative belinda come get your
white sheep
this is today this is tomorrow
right there yep
okay it's tomorrow
go get it yeah yeah
okay i was just
okay
just get your white sheet from
representative petrina
for the one you made the motions on
okay
all right up next will be hb 1436.
oh no i'm sorry
1458.
limiting harassing or intimidating court
filings in family
court proceedings representative yokela
do you have a motion
i move itl
second
seconded by representative d simone is
there any discussion
all right seeing none i'll have the
clerk call the roll when he's ready
representative desimone
yes representative desimone votes yes
representative yo keller yes
representative your color votes yes
representative nelson yes representative
nelson votes yes representative belanger
representative belanger votes yes
representative litchfield
yes representative litchfield votes yes
representative smith
representative smith votes yes
representative long representative long
votes yes representative alessia
representative alessia votes yes
representative grossman
representative grossman votes yes
representative levesque
representative levesque votes yes
representative wazir
representative waziri votes yes
representative petrino the clerk that's
me votes yes
representative altula yes representative
alterla votes yes madam chair rice yes
madam chair rice votes yes the vote is
14-0 without objection consent
yes
yeah i called the clerk
yeah oh so
on consent yep
okay where am i at
uh that was that was oh okay i wrote
this on the wrong thing
all right
uh 1253 relative the choice of counselor
to evaluate a child in family court
proceedings
representative belanger do you have a
motion
okay second
seconded by representative desimone any
discussion right seeing none i'll have
the clerk call the roll
when he's ready no pressure what number
is this representative
yes representative desimone votes yes
representative yokela yes representative
yokola votes yes representative nelson
yes representative nelson votes yes
representative belanger
representative belanger votes yes
representative litchfield yes
representative litchfield votes yes
representative smith
representative smith votes yes
representative long yes representative
long votes yes representative alicia
representative alecia votes yes
representative grossman
representative grossman votes yes
representative levesque
representative levesque votes yes
representative wazir
representative wazir votes yes
representative petrino that's me the
clerk i vote yes
representative altschuler yes
representative although votes yes madam
chair rice yes
chairman rice votes yes the vote is 14
to zero without objection consent
and then we'll have hb 1199
prohibiting reunification therapy
when you're ready
thank you
okay representative belanger do you have
a motion
second
seconded by representative desimone
is there any discussion
seeing none i'll have the clerk call the
roll when he's ready
representative desimone yes
representative desamond votes yes
representative joe keller yes
representative yokola votes yes
representative nelson
representative nelson votes yes
representative belanger
representative belanger votes yes
representative litchfield
representative litchfield votes yes
representative smith
representative smith votes yes
representative long
representative long votes yes
representative alessia
representative alessia votes yes
representative grossman
representative grossman votes yes
representative levesque
representative levesque votes yes
representative wazir
representative wazir votes yes
representative petrino
that's me the clerk i vote yes
representative although
representative alterla votes yes
madam chair rice
yes adam share rice votes yes the vote
is fourteen to zero without without
objection on consent
next we'll do 15 11
when everyone's ready
okay
the exact session on hb 15 11
representative nelson do you have a
motion
yes madam chair i make a motion to itl
okay second seconded by representative d
simone is there any discussion
all right seeing none i'll have the
clerk call the roll
thank you
representative testimony yes
representative desimona votes yes
representative yokela
yes representative yokela votes yes
representative nelson
yes representative nelson votes yes
representative belangia
representative belanger votes yes
representative litchfield
yes representative litchfield votes yes
representative smith
representative smith votes yes
representative long yes representative
long votes yes representative alessia
representative alessia votes yes
representative grossman
representative grossman votes yes
representative levesque
representative levesque votes yes
representative wazir
representative wazir votes yes
representative petrino the clerk lets me
i vote yes
representative altsuller
representative altila votes yes madam
chair rice
yes
madam chair rice votes yes the vote is
14 to zero
without objection consent and i think
that's it for today
unless were we were we itl in
1568 you guys um
that's the 68. yeah
oh 14.65 no 1568.
okay all right so we'll do one more and
then we'll be done thanks everybody for
your patience we'll do um house bill
1568 representative
what
okay
representative belanger do you have a
motion
okay
second
seconded by representative desimone
did you want to speak to your motion
well with regret itl
okay idl with regret we can't put that
in the calendar
but i get it i have to see that first
thank you all right so
the motion is itl on house bill 5068 i
will have the clerk call the roll
when he's ready
thank you madam chair
representative desimone
yes
representative desimone volksier
representative yokela enthusiastically
yes representative yokela
representative yokela
yes representative yokela votes yes
representative nelson
representative nelson votes yes
representative belanger
representative votes yes representative
cross
excuse me absent today representative
litchfield yes representative litchfield
votes yes representative smith
representative smith votes yes
representative long yes representative
long votes yes representative alessia
representative alessia votes yes
representative grossman
representative grossman votes yes
representative levesque
representative levesque votes yes
representative wazir
representative wazir votes yes
representative petrino the clerk that's
me i vote yes representative altula
representative alterla votes yes madam
chair rice yes madam chair rice votes
yes the vote is 14 to zero without
objection consent
and that's it for today so if you're
writing a committee report
i'll let you leave with them today but i
have to have them by noon tomorrow
okay
noon tomorrow
does anyone need
the paper the paper to do theirs or does
everyone have them
yes
okay i think everybody's got them
yep
jody you have the ones you need right
do you need any more
one more yeah
can you pass that down to jody
well thanks you guys this was super easy
everybody go home we'll be back in the
morning and and let's just knock them
out by noon
okay and we're over in our regular
committee room tomorrow so we'll all be
able to look at each other again
all right thank you
what no nope our committee our committee
person will come and get everything
all right okay so
here's this one that's cody's i'll give
you that today oh do i get no i give
that to karen i'm sorry
i'll try to keep them all together so i
can give them to karen tomorrow or
actually i should give her that one
tonight
yeah i don't want her to
i don't want to overwhelm her
all right thanks everybody i know it was
a long day